[Music]
[Laughter]
hey you guys
it's friday
yeah friday open line friday tonight
just turning on my effects in the other
room that way my specialist because the
sun's got starting to go down
and uh time gets away from me and i walk
out there and it's dark and [ __ ] so
then he trips and falls over got all
these damn smart lights and stuff
turning [ __ ] on
turn the [ __ ] on get ready like i said
this whole upstairs looks like a [ __ ]
we got all these lights yeah looks like
there's like a [ __ ] disco up in here
[Laughter]
yeah and then we got refrigerators and
[ __ ] ice makers out there i'm gonna put
a bar out there
it'd look good well yeah that's what we
were talking about so we were thinking
of making cause
uh i think we maybe mentioned this
earlier but the upstairs of this house
has like this big long
kind of semi-open room which i guess is
like a second living room
uh because the living room downstairs is
you know it's kind of small it's a
little bit small
well there's two of them really well
yeah there's a formal one in the front
that's like part living apart dining
room and then there's like a den
but there's like a really big long
open living room up here
and uh
so we were thinking
maybe eventually we could make that into
a break room yeah like
you know cook them in a bar yeah because
we have the mini fridge and we have the
ice maker i have a coffee maker in here
um you know so i can make coffee without
bothering you
and put some damn console video games
out there retro and i was kind of
thinking maybe we could even put a
microwave and perhaps even a toaster
oven yeah
out there that would be kind of neat and
then then we could be super lazy and
never have to go downstairs ever except
to like take out the garbage and [ __ ]
they're selling those three-quarter
scale
uh console games classic ones like
pac-man and [ __ ] missile command and
all that [ __ ]
they're not that expensive i was
thinking about getting some of those and
put them against the wall it would just
look good really
more than anything else if you had
guests over
those [ __ ] are all drinkers
anyway we just [ __ ] be lounging
around out there in that discotheque
looking we'd all be laying around
video games i think pretending that it's
the [ __ ] 80s
[Laughter]
cheryl says love your hair jenny thank
you all right
i almost forgot that i had this purple
one yeah uh cause i was gonna wear the
black and blue one and then i was like
oh wait no i kind of like that purple
one because it has like a little bit the
black and blue one is more like middle
you know middle part whereas this one's
kind of more side part yeah and i was
kind of like i'm kind of feeling that
today i'm kind of feeling the purple i
have one just like this except it's
green
um
which i like but that one looks like
really really artificial yeah you know
what i mean a wig
yeah would you
yeah i mean i've seen other people
wearing it before but that has to be i
was actually going to use the green one
because last halloween before i you know
ran out of money or ran out of time or
whatever like i usually do i was
actually going to do like evil mermaid
and i was gonna wear that green wig for
that
but
maybe i'll do it this year i was
thinking the other day isn't this dumb
it's [ __ ] february and i'm already
kind of like maybe i should start buying
like stuff for my halloween costume now
so i don't yeah well i was thinking
about it because i was watching yeah i
know what i'm gonna buy because i was
watching jade the libra who like i said
she her big thing is like halloween
hauls and she starts looking for
halloween decorations in
june because some stores like put them
out that early sometimes like june or
july
and she was out the other day
she put up a new video and she was kind
of like i heard that michaels had some
leftover halloween [ __ ] that they didn't
sell and they put it up and she went to
the michaels but it was already all sold
out so she decided she was going to do
valloween as in halloween and
valentine's day so she just bought like
creepy looking valentine's day [ __ ] and
like made a halloween valentine tree it
was actually like pretty cool looking
but uh yeah so she just put a new one up
the other day so i thought that was kind
of cute but so it got me thinking about
maybe i should start planning for
halloween as well because it always like
sneaks up on me man even though it's at
the same [ __ ] time every year i'm
always kind of like it's always like two
weeks away and i'm like oh [ __ ] i didn't
even like what am i gonna get what am i
gonna now i don't have any money and all
this other kind of stuff so maybe i
should just like buy little pieces like
over the year and then i'll have it all
together you know they're playing with
the little mice so much she really likes
i mean you know auntie ilsa sent those
man pookie loves those she throws them
with one hand and [ __ ] yeah
then she steps on with her back feet
she like kicks at him she's so funny if
you don't throw the mice around for us
she's just she's like well [ __ ] it i'm
just gonna do it myself she picks it up
in one pond like slings it and then
chases after it
um grampus asked me well if you put
another bar up there one should be just
a new oasis for the roaches
uh when we moved in here man i found a
lot of dead roaches looking there was a
roach infestation when i pulled that
[ __ ]
uh
dishwasher out there was a bunch back
there [ __ ] no not like big florida no
just like german cocktails those german
ones which are in a way like worse
in the infestation since they're worse
because they can get into anything and
it's really really hard to get rid of
that but uh haven't seen them back you
know [ __ ] i went in there and cleaned
all that [ __ ] out vacuumed them all out
[ __ ] washed the inside disinfected
uh because you know people that used to
live here they're [ __ ] nasty but uh
it's fixed haven't seen any
roaches that scared me in terms of like
that's an infester you know i haven't
seen any bugs in here and on it and i
have a coffee pot in here every time
although i do keep it clean but
every time i saw a roach in here it's
been twice since we've been in here and
it was because it was hot out and i had
the windows open
because they'll come into the windows
uh this is just it's a constant battle
but
i got everything i got all the [ __ ]
sprays and everything i got to [ __ ]
go around this house and make sure to
respray again the outside
just florida
this is a tropical sub-tropical area
uh they're going to try to get in that's
just it's a cup this is not
and you know [ __ ] people some people say
you know i've heard these [ __ ]
yankees and i can't move down there the
roaches well i guess you've never been
in a [ __ ] new york new york new york
city is one [ __ ] roach infestation
one single trojan yeah but they're not
like the big huge scary roads yeah
they're like we have down here which are
alarming yeah alarmingly large yeah the
thing is though like i said before those
big ones we call them palmetto bugs
they're not infesters
they don't they can infest the house i
mean but your house has to be pretty you
got to be [ __ ] up to get those to
infest i mean they do come in your house
yes they have the opportunity that's not
an infestation no an infestation is when
they're [ __ ] living and breeding in
large numbers
and uh you got to call in and [ __ ] a
fumigator have the house people again
those typically don't
infest because they're big so you notice
it early on
and uh one they come in one at a time
and you kill them they can't escape
detection or in our case the kitties
killed yeah the kiddies kill them
what the [ __ ] happened i've opened it in
the middle of the night and seen pookie
jumping up and down three feet off the
ground
and i'm going what what what what what
and i hit grab the flashlight like that
she's like daddy daddy she'll be
smacking one looking at me get it get it
yeah because
pookie doesn't want to touch them and
they were like good girl i don't blame
her i don't want to touch them either
they're dirty so i gotta get up and
[ __ ] hunt but she'll try to corner it
get it get it she'll help me
no she's a good girl beige doesn't give
a [ __ ] she'll just eat them she'll just
[ __ ] tear it apart in a piece and
spit it out and then sit back there like
she did some [ __ ] she's like killed that
one right with that big fluffy tail
yeah so but the ones you gotta worry
about is little tiny german cockroaches
those are the ones you gotta worry about
and some of them are like they're not
even they're smaller than a german
cockroach or a black dot
those those are [ __ ]
bad if they get it into the house and
they come in
through food
because they come in through if
you can buy a package
at a damn grocery store
if you went to the wrong grocery store
like a walmart and something sat there
too long they'll get into a package
you'll bring it into a house and then
they'll get release themselves in your
[ __ ] pantry and try to make a trojan
horse like a trojan horse for a little
bitty roaches you just gotta it's just
not so dumb it's a southern skill you
gotta [ __ ] stay on top of it
you got to leave poison out spray
regularly well and you really you can't
leave anything like you can't leave
dirty dishes in the sink overnight you
can't leave anything out on your counter
sweet mop you got a sweet mop you gotta
like wipe down the counters like every
like all the time because you can't let
them get a foothold man and like i said
you don't have to be that dirty no but
once they get a [ __ ] football once
they get in that's it uh oscar says you
misunderstood tom granthars is calling
the customers at the oasis roaches
i don't know
i haven't been there in a while i gotta
go back maybe i'll go tomorrow
yeah we don't uh you know we don't have
anything going on tomorrow yeah yeah
it's saturday
they were all out his motorcycles
everywhere today when i went out to go
[ __ ] buy the booze they're everywhere
i was thinking is it
bike week no no bike week happened
already no it wouldn't have it's usually
in march is it
yeah i used to live in daytona yeah i
know this [ __ ] i'm local i don't worry
about bike week i know but i'm just i'm
just saying that maybe that's why there
were so many people out
um but bike week doesn't usually happen
bike week is usually sometime in march
and then biketoberfest obviously is in
mid to late october depending
um
somebody says 100 says thanks for a
great show every film i liked uh
watching growing up seems to be on your
channel yeah well we did we we're
showing what we like we're talking about
what we liked and what we liked [ __ ]
that was that you liked basically and if
we were the same generation
then a lot of us like what even though
back then
you didn't realize that other people
were seeing the same [ __ ] it wasn't
until like i was much older and saw
people the same age as me like
reminiscing yeah about the stuff that
was on cable and stuff and i was just
like oh my god yeah because you just get
it in there back you didn't know what
other people liked right uh a couple
days ago somebody heard something in the
comment section i was going to mention
it but it went by uh uh without now we
invited i forgot to mention it
somebody was thinking i forgot who it
was somebody had thanked me for um
talking about hunter prey that they
watched it and [ __ ] loved it
hunter pray is a good movie and you can
see it for free on youtube and it's sad
because it's not really streaming
anywhere and i think it needs more
attention because like i said i'm really
into supporting
indie filmmakers
uh people that are really into
making the movies they don't need a lot
of money and if they're really good then
but and like i said it's so much easier
for them nowadays because there's so
many streaming services but it's a shame
that that one's not really honorable
yeah the unofficial sequel to enemy mind
yeah and and going back and looking at
that motherfucker's manly as hell that
was a [ __ ] and everybody's an alien
it's it's macho aliens
macho aliens macho militarized aliens
fighting on a damn desert planet
talking [ __ ] on a desert planet but it
all kind of works out like we do yeah
like they do
amanda gear says oh love the hair by the
way jenny thank you yeah i was saying
that she looks totally different with
long hair and parted in the middle or on
the side and she looks real well i
chopped black one partnered in this
remember the black one that was parted
on this
i don't have a brown wig we discussed
this okay
i thought it was a real dark i have no i
have here's the wigs i have i have this
purple one
i have a short red one that's about
shoulder length and kind of wavy and is
kind of swept over to the side like this
i have one exactly like this except it's
green yeah i have one that is parted in
the middle and that is black on the top
and then like ombre down into blue i
have that i have uh
one that is black but shorter kind of
like a betty page type of situation
although i don't like that one that much
it doesn't look that good right it's
kind of a bob but it's a little bit of a
long bob i don't like it because the um
the what do you call them the bangs are
too long and it's i put it on and i look
like a ramone and i'm just like not into
it well we can cut that yeah i need to
cut it yeah and honestly it looks kind
of like my real hair so i'm just kind of
like okay whatever i mean i when i
bought it like i saw it on the model i
was like oh that looks cute but then
when i put it on i'm like that doesn't
look anything like the picture but okay
uh she must have cut it is all i'm
saying and i have one that is red and
curly
that i bought when i was amy from fright
night yeah like so it's like a big red
long curly or like i said looks like uh
the chick from brave that
animated movie
and
i think that's it and then i have some
other like clip in things like i have
these big like black and red
long ponytails
i wear those out a lot yeah although
they usually give me a headache because
they're very heavy we need to get you
one that's nothing but braids
yeah that would be cute
oh and i have like some ponytails that
clip in that are bright red and that are
like curly
yeah i think is that it i don't think
they sell bread you braided ones you
probably have to make the braids
yourself huh
they sell all kinds of [ __ ] they sell
all kinds of [ __ ]
i mean it depends on how much you want
to pay for the [ __ ] i mean obviously the
more elaborate the [ __ ] is the more
expensive it is
you can look on etsy because there's
like people on there selling all kind of
like crazy [ __ ] headpieces and [ __ ]
now some of them are expensive and
rightfully so because a lot of work goes
into them
but
you know
you can uh john says that you look
mexican with that wig
[Laughter]
i am decidedly not mexican yeah
cheryl says cinemassacre put up a great
nostalgia video today brought back
memories oh might have to watch that
later i like cinemassacre did you see
that he put up and this is probably like
a few
this might have been back around
halloween i don't know i lost all sense
of time but he put up one that was like
horror it was monster madness so it was
around halloween it was monster madness
around the world and then he like edited
all of them together so it was like
three hours long or something and he
talked about
all these movies from like all these
different countries and it was so good
like i just sat there and watched the
whole [ __ ] thing you know what i mean
yeah i like that guy what's his name
james something
uh oscar says in what universe does
jenny look mexican
people just gonna say whatever you know
yeah
yeah my actual hair
it was like well because remember it was
like shaved underneath for a long time
and
i guess i got lazy
and stopped shaving it not necessarily
because i wanted to but just because i
was lazy
and then like the rest of it was really
long and then i was like man this is
looking like really [ __ ] up because
underneath it's kind of growing out and
it's like
short but like not i don't know and it's
just like at a really awkward length and
so it was like this weird thing where it
kind of looked like i had a mullet a
little bit
uh so then like the long part i said
well i'm just gonna cut this short like
to shoulder length so at least it'll be
closer
to
how long the hair underneath is
and then so it'll all grow to the same
length quicker
but then see when i cut my hair short
it's my hair is very uh
the individual hairs are very fine like
baby hair but i have
a lot of hair
so when i cut it short it goes poof
and like it makes this poofy
triangle situation and i'm not into it
um so
i don't know it's difficult my hair just
does not ever like to cooperate which is
why i started buying wigs because
man
i just get so depressed look at my
[ __ ] hair sometimes it's such a it's
such a mess it's not just her
though
[ __ ] pretty much every goth girl the
[ __ ] we know all the guy females it's
wigs it's so much easier yeah to be
honest all this [ __ ] you'll see them on
instagram and all the stuff online these
fantastic [ __ ] hair and all this
looking you just totally made up these
look like something off a damn movie you
know it's wigs yeah you can't get the
human hair to do that [ __ ] no a lot of
those girls just basically don't have
hair a couple of them don't they're bald
i don't think i haven't considered that
if i didn't have a huge big fat bowling
ball of a head um
i know i do um
i'm i'm aware
thank you thank you you don't see thank
you for backing that up it doesn't look
like a bowling ball when you have hair
when you have big hair it you can't tell
i do but i do have a big [ __ ] well i
have a really round face
you know so and i have like kind of a
big head so i don't know if it's a big
head necessarily but i just have like a
rounds you got a round face so yeah and
you know i don't love it but you know
what are you gonna do the only way to
get her face unround she's got to be
pretty underweight real underweight yeah
the only time i actually kind of had a
pointy chin was when i weighed like 90.
much less than i should have 110 would
you wait 118 was 18 was the lowest i got
and i looked a little bit ill her mom
looked like piazza dora yeah pizza dora
[ __ ] has a big chubby face chubby
cheeks and [ __ ]
yeah i have like this i have like the
kind of linda blair yeah
she is adorable
when she gains weight she puts a lot of
it on her face yeah sadly yeah sadly uh
i wish that wasn't true but
genetics is the way you use the way you
put genetics is a [ __ ] it's funny
she'll only put on weight around around
her midriff and her face nowhere else
yeah like the two places where i least
want this issue where it shows them
is this gee thanks nature it's brutal
see nature hates me brutal nature hates
me
natural sucks
it does that's why i'm just supernatural
now i said [ __ ]
i'll go straight to chemistry
well you know a lot of his age too i
mean if i could afford plastic surgery i
would probably get it
not a lot i don't mind my face normally
i just don't like it's i don't like the
roundness we're at the we're at that age
you know
i don't like the roundness so i would
like a better jawline but i don't i like
there's i don't mind my nose i used to
hate my nose when i was a kid i used to
think i had a big fat nose too but i
don't actually mind my nose now uh
but that's that's one thing i would
take it we got to take a trip to
thailand one of these days the prices
are a lot cheaper on that but we have to
go down there with a big wad of cash see
and [ __ ] a lot of [ __ ] anabolics
and stuff are [ __ ] legal over the
counter and cheap there you know a lot
of guys
a lot of a lot of bodybuilders go there
for vacations
to [ __ ] juice up on cycle and they
get plastic surgery
all right i do i wouldn't mind have been
tightened up a little bit underneath
here i mean
yeah i mean
they need to peel my [ __ ] off and like
pull it like put their foot behind my
head and pull it in the entertainment
world staple that [ __ ] in the
entertainment world none of them
[ __ ] are natural they've all
unless unless they've made a living
being [ __ ] ugly
they're all
doing little tweaks or here and there
from the age of like 35. but it's so
gradual that you don't notice it i mean
if you do a little bit at a time
starting when you're younger yeah that's
what they're doing that's probably what
the better way to go about it because if
you wait until you look like hell and
then you get a whole bunch of [ __ ] done
then it's going to look like just look
at bart reynolds then it's going to look
like super weird like i said it's good
yeah it's going to look like you're
going to look like [ __ ] uh
the cenobites like pulled your face off
and like you know what i mean
like stretched it over something else
it's like
a [ __ ] they're going to places like
thailand and mexico there's some places
on the border of mexico at least there
was i don't know if it's still there but
um just over over the [ __ ] border in
el paso
they've got some damn
resorts down there
it's like a it's like a holiday resort
you stay there and the doctors are
working right out on the offices right
there in that resort and you get little
things done a thousand dollars at a time
you know and you stay there for a couple
days in that damn resort healing up and
then you fly back
because you can't really afford it here
in the united states the insurance is so
much for these doctors they want to
charge you [ __ ] five grand just for
anything well yeah i certainly can
honestly and these are and when if you
actually were to see a video of what
they're doing these are body
modifications that our freaky friends
would do to each other [ __ ] for free
without [ __ ] anesthesia and sometimes
they'd be like like [ __ ]
some of the people that we know to do
all that piercings and [ __ ]
they do some [ __ ] hardcore stuff
without any [ __ ] anesthesia like
[ __ ] aurora will suspend herself from
a ceiling with [ __ ] spikes that are
nearly like three-quarters of an inch
back going through the muscles of her
back yeah
and she just all right well
some of that facelift stuff i'm i'm
looking at it and going yeah i could do
that
like i wouldn't let you like that's in
my face though
i can't imagine how the problem the
problem
the problem
is the risk of something going wrong
well yeah and that's the problem
you know uh
infection although i think pretty sure i
can avoid that or something happens and
somebody starts bleeding out or there's
some kind of a reaction yeah then then
what would you do you'd be like oh what
do you do now right you know so that's
the risk
but uh you know
the romans would do it without
anesthesia
and without [ __ ] um
they knew that things had to be clean
but they would do uh uh they would do
surgeries on gynecomastia guys that had
[ __ ] tits they could [ __ ] get up in
there and do that evidently they could
do boob jobs but they don't know how it
must have been fat transferal
nobody knows what they were doing but
there's there's a couple of references
to making breasts larger in in roman
literature ancient roman literature
hey you know i don't know why my brain
just went here but remember when last
night we were watching smokey and the
bandit and i said man i wonder what my
cb handle would be i would like it to be
[ __ ] tits [ __ ] did
[Laughter]
just just putting that at it um i'm
watching smoking the bennett last night
it was a fun movie to see it again after
all these years yeah i hadn't seen it
since i was a kid i saw it a million
times when i was a kid yeah because they
played that [ __ ] forever on camera i
wanted to say i want to uh amanda gear
says what kind of necklace is that jenny
i always see you wear it uh this is
actually two necklaces this one's just
like a bead one and this one here is uh
that's good old hp lovecraft
right there i got that from a friend of
mine i think she got it from like an
etsy store somewhere that does like a
bunch of uh ones like that grampur's
hammer says i've been to thailand can't
say i'd get any form of intrusive
surgery there
uh no they got good stuff there whitney
graham says good evening tom and jenny
hi nice to nice to see you yeah is weed
legal in every state yet um
i don't know who cares i don't think so
i don't think so but
there's there's not that many left
though yeah and it really does oscar
says texas will be the last place to
legalize it probably it
people get all hung up over that [ __ ]
just because it's illegal doesn't mean
it's not happening
it doesn't mean it doesn't well
obviously it doesn't mean you're not
doing it
you know there's a lot of [ __ ] that's
illegal
laws that are on the books that even the
cops don't know that that's on the books
so it's just not honestly you know what
i give a [ __ ] about i wish that i liked
weed more yeah it's not that good i kind
of well maybe i just never had any good
[ __ ] but i've had the best we'll see
well i mean it people react to it
differently like and i have a friend uh
who
you know uh has like a lot of anxiety
and she started doing it and she's like
really into it and i was kind of like oh
well you know i that'd be kind of cool
like because i sort of need to be
mellowed out sometimes because i'm you
know
you know i have a lot of anxiety and
like i always have like my brains always
going to mile a minute and i wish i
could like [ __ ] chill out
and so i tried to do it a few times
and weed makes me even more
anxious and paranoid and i'm like i
don't need this yeah i thought it was
supposed to do the opposite of like this
is not fun not at all i always thought
it was i mean
i got friends that were [ __ ] growing
[ __ ] that was just such a
monstrous
it was always just a cheap drug to me
you know what i mean and
not that interesting it's nothing
compared to lsd
see i i was a fan of lsd
that did
what i thought weed was gonna do that
made me feel like oh man everything's
all right lsd is a man's drug whoa
yeah it's like this is awesome yeah i
loved it and cocaine is [ __ ] awesome
but it's very seductive and real
expensive and you have to know how to
control that um
number one rule with cocaine is don't
buy
any only accept cocaine as a gift for
free
then just do it one time have a good
time yeah and then you know right uh
never allow never allow anybody to give
you some free cocaine and then come back
do you want any more of that got no i'm
good yeah i'm good because you start
buying
yeah you know no gram there's hammer
said weed stores on every corner in
michigan more weed stores than starbucks
well yeah because as soon as it got
legalized in a lot of places man
everybody like opened up a small
business as you would i mean you know uh
cheryl said i wish i liked weed too
makes me nervous yeah same uh it's not
that good and uh
somebody else yeah murder hornet return
says weed makes me paranoid same
um you know i did it a few times like i
said hoping that it would like chill me
out more
and all it did
it did this really weird thing where it
made me
feel like one everyone's looking at me
which is bad i don't really need to be
feeling like that um because i already
kind of feel like they should not want
to move well
like it made me like a hundred times
more self-conscious like i'm already
self-conscious and i was like okay i
don't need this [ __ ] and also
it made everything seem like
uh
like i was missing like five or ten
seconds at a time like [ __ ] was like
skipping ahead you know what i mean like
if you skipped through a movie like 10
seconds 10 seconds 10 seconds it seemed
like that and i was like ooh i don't
like that either
i didn't like it in terms of drugs that
you can smoke the best one i ever had
was opium and that was when i was in
egypt but you could get opium [ __ ]
real good quality opium
you just sit around just relax and smoke
opium all right
now heroin is probably like a hundred
times that
yes i i've never done that but you can
imagine what that would be like i would
never [ __ ] with heroin because that
would be like entering the realm of
heaven or something you would never want
to come out of that
you just sit around about sleep well a
lot of people did yeah a lot of people
do [ __ ] that i mean as with everything
it depends on the person because it
affects different people differently
some people can take heroin and still
kind of function yeah some people not so
much
i've never seen anybody actually walk
away from heroin unscathed though true
the dudes that i knew that did that it
kind of made him a piece of [ __ ]
and uh every one of them now when i look
back on all the guys that i knew that
were they're all dead now
either by accidents or by their own hand
you know because rich killed himself on
that
and like i said i can think of like some
rock stars that did heroin a lot back in
the day like nick cave or iggy pop or
something like that who are still going
and still look good and still have their
[ __ ] together because they slipped but
yeah maybe that's why they're like
preserved
um and seem to have gotten away from it
but
you could never build a good body on
heroin though you're going to be skinny
or real fat or
or something depends on what you're
skinny usually because you'll be too too
wired to [ __ ] eat you don't really
care well yeah like it's unhealthy very
unhealthy but their metabolisms are
moving so slowly
they sleep so much
they can live a long time
uh but rich killed himself in an
argument
blew his head off in front of his
girlfriend during an argument over
[ __ ] the volume of television which
sounds like more of a drunk thing than a
heroin thing he was drinking all the
time also but
it was
his brain was [ __ ] frying out he was
losing all his friends because he was
just loaded all the time he was a great
guy though liked him he was an ex-army
veteran
used to hang out with him up in michigan
you know michigan should be um
massachusetts
boston he was the old goth guy
and he was
[ __ ] i was in my uh late 20s at that
time and he was in his his early 50s and
he
looked like he was in his 30s in real
good shape
and he just kind of went from one 20
year old goth check to the next over and
over these little goth stripper types
because if you if you have heroin
you all of a sudden become very popular
with women they just
because they're [ __ ] junkies you know
i mean it's a well with junky women you
become popular not with all women
they're not what you would think a
junkie would be like you know they're
[ __ ] in those days they had the
heroin chic thing going on this is 90s
and they were like got fetish models
you know and he was a good-looking guy
though but
you layer in the fact that he constantly
had heroin
and he didn't have a
he had a job but only kind of a little
bit he was the caretaker of the building
that he was living if
that he lived in on commonwealth avenue
downtown michigan downtown uh mass
boston and massachusetts
so he had a really good job
um he didn't have to go anywhere he'd
just go fix a pipe and then come back
and they just [ __ ] shoot up and
[ __ ]
hang out with these girls and have sex
with them and [ __ ]
he's always trying to have [ __ ]
threesomes and foursomes and [ __ ] and
[ __ ] he'd have all these [ __ ]
hotties and they were like the girls
from the barbiturates the the dancers
from sleep chamber
yes yeah it was those girls
it was another time and it was funny
because you'd be hanging out with them
and uh like whatever happened to you
know whatever happened to to merge you
know or some [ __ ] like that because all
these funny ass names and like oh her oh
she died like what
yeah she died two weeks ago
she's dead i kind of feel like and i
don't know i don't know it's like not a
big deal to them what happened to you oh
dude
i don't have any numbers to back this up
but it does seem like
gen xers yeah are
like a lot of them are dying young of
[ __ ] like that yeah
you know what i mean but they would just
talk about it like it was nothing oh oh
her oh she's dead
like what that's not she just hanging
out with us like couple weeks ago you
know what i mean [ __ ] just hot i
could show you guys really like well
[ __ ] happens people od i guess i'll show
you the videos of the girl i'm talking
well i guess they're so used to it
happening that they're just kind of like
yeah there goes another one i'm gonna
i'm gonna find it there's a video of the
girl that i'm talking about on youtube
i'll show it to you cheryl says i have
some mushrooms too scared to take them
lol i was actually and then zach says
i'm worried if i took lsd i'd wake up
afterwards in a drainage dish probably
missing an arm and my dick lmao um
honestly i was a little bit nervous to
take it but the thing about lsd is that
um
the experience that you have is largely
dependent on how you
kind of go into it i was like kind of
excited to take it you know what i mean
i'd always kind of wanted to yeah and
um
this is the girl i'm talking about hold
on they're going to show her here in a
minute
that's her
i asked where she was because oh she
died
yeah
but that's what they look like
that's my friend john there he's singing
this is like uh i don't know
96.
yeah died
well we just got demonetized
[Laughter]
why why would that be
uh because that might be copyrighted and
also and also ass no it's on youtube
that's youtube we'll see that's youtube
we'll see
um but the thing about lsd that i
enjoyed
was that
you got all the best stuff of being
drunk
as in
lack of inhibitions kind of more
fun more that kind of thing like
open-minded
but it didn't have
like you didn't have the blackout aspect
of you know what i mean because
sometimes you get drunk and you just
like start babbling and like [ __ ]
you forget what you said the next day
and stuff
it didn't have that you were still like
really lucid it's like really hard to
explain if you haven't done it but
you're still
you're still lucid you're still aware of
everything but
so it's almost kind of like you see all
this weird [ __ ]
but you know that it's not real
you know
but yeah so it was like that so i really
enjoyed that experience
you know
um
murder hornet return says my dad was an
alcoholic and he recently switched to
thc gummy bears and he quit alcohol wow
forza down says i used to enjoy
mushrooms they gave me the worst
hangovers i've ever had
that's the thing about lsd is that i
will tell you that you will feel like
absolute crap the next day
absolute crap
like it was i actually
went to work the next day
and
man i i've been to work hungover lots of
times more times than i'd like to count
i know it's terrible but this was by far
the worst
but it was so fun i didn't really mind
all that much but man the next day god
damn i felt awful
mostly just um
[Music]
sore like everything was sore
my face was sore
i just i don't know it it's not even the
same thing as a hangover it kind of felt
like i don't even know what it felt like
but it was like having that big [ __ ]
smile on your face all night yeah that's
probably what it was yeah like my face
like was all the muscles in my face were
sore
uh
let's see where was okay we got some
more russian bots thank you very much
zach
if gen x is dying young imagine how
millennials would be
with the forever ways double econ
crashes pandemic all in the last 20
years yeah you know
we'll see how it goes i hope you guys do
better than we do but
uh tammy says uh my uncle was a 63 year
old pothead founded a former teacher's
mid 60s is one also
and
murder returns shrooms grow wild outside
the hospital here sent tom pictures he
can vouch yeah grampur's hammer said
true story when i was a game warden in
oregon a guy ate a bunch of peyote then
got into a 160 degree hot spring in the
desert he died and cooked for a week
he came apart like a crock pot chicken
damn
oh [ __ ]
that was a pro tip that was too much
peyote yeah that was too much peyote
don't maybe do a little bit less than
that
more to it than that you don't want to
be like looking like there had to be
something more to look at
like heat exhaustion in there maybe
maybe but
peyote is not that
strong really
what's tom's favorite marinade to use on
chicken it depends on what kind of
chicken i'm making we talk about some
italian or mexican or are we talking
what kind of chicken are we talking
about
yeah because we
make a lot of
mexican food yeah there isn't and a lot
of indian food yeah there isn't just one
marinade you know there's a bunch of
them
gran there's hammer said i drove his
remains to the medical examiner two body
bags in the back of my work truck [ __ ]
did anybody make a joke about like
making them into soup or anything i mean
why did my brain go there i don't know
but that's like what i thought of i
guess because i've been watching a lot
of food videos lately maybe that's why
joshua says damn that sucks she was hot
yeah she was very hot so i was asking
about where she was
yeah she was only about
probably 23 24.
she was also a stripper but she was
one of john's um performance artist when
he
put on a show
he had about six or seven of them
and um they were always hanging out the
parties and it was it was a drug scene
but very much so they were very cool
uh they weren't dumb or anything they
were [ __ ]
kind of cultured it was kind of like
something out of i don't know
kind of like
kind of like something out of the velvet
underground or you know or
um you know it's kind of like andy
warholish type scene
the problem is is that they they thought
they were immune to things
no [ __ ] there are repercussions to
what you do
and a lot of them died
yeah it's not just there then though i
mean we know people that have died
recently out of our scene
in the past couple years six seven years
[ __ ] mike stone died that's right um
that was a lot of the girls that [ __ ]
he hung out with who were hot as [ __ ]
they died you were like oh yeah she died
and they were like and they were just
kind of new to the scene we never even
really got to know them remember which
one i'm talking about yeah there's a
couple of real cuties yeah yeah yeah i
know you're talking and you saw him for
like a couple months and then never saw
them again you found out that they died
and never any details but you just know
it was drug related
although the weird thing is like yeah
that's happened but then we've had
people
die or from like natural causes cancer
like cancer cancers car accidents brain
tumors like that kind of stuff like
young ass people not even gen x
younger the z yeah gen z not even
millennials yeah not even c
some of them just turned up dead
which crazy yeah so maybe that's why i
was thinking that because we do actually
and it didn't have anything to do with
like drug overdoses or anything although
we do know some people that
died of drug overdoses like recently but
we've had some you know we talked about
our friend kaylee who died from cancer
she was 34. yeah she just unlucky and
she just got cancer and died didn't do
anything wrong i mean we have two other
friends that have cancer that are still
and she was like thankfully
yeah
man [ __ ] we used to take her [ __ ] we
used to pick her up and drive her every
week yeah to the club we used to go to
venue 13 every [ __ ] week with her
make it out in front of her that's it
that's true all kinds of crazy should
have and then turned out she
croaked
got married she married a chick
and then died then they broke up and she
died
yeah her way well they well they were
still legally married yeah because i
mean
no they weren't oh weren't they they
were still divorced okay forced and then
turned out she had cancer and died
yeah
because i remember hearing that they got
divorced because they moved away yeah
they moved to where north carolina or
georgia or somewhere georgia or north
carolina yeah she's a little bitty
little bitty goth girl her mom was
mexican she's a little half mexican cop
chick real cute
i mean crazy yeah krampur's hammer said
is ecstasy big in the goth scene no
no you know what nowadays um
i i don't really know if there's
anything unless you know
maybe yeah i guess
that's the closest thing to that that's
around but but you don't really see it
like you used to i mean like back in the
70s 80s
you know everybody was on something yeah
most people were on drugs have kind of
taken a hiatus nobody really cares about
that [ __ ] it's like people will do like
every like pretty much everybody well
not everybody because not me but like
most people smoke weed okay that's not
even considered weird yeah that's like
not even a drug um
you're not even enforcing that one right
that's what i mean so it's just kind of
like that's just kind of like a whatever
is it is it legal we're laughing they're
like what the [ __ ] this is it
it doesn't matter this is [ __ ]
florida well honestly 80s and 90s you
could go into a club and you'd have a
pile of cocaine and they'd be snorting
it yeah in miami
even though technically it was that was
illegal as [ __ ] and they were dizzy
right they were snoring cocaine in the
clubs they didn't care what was illegal
this is moss eisley star port here
basically but yeah
i mean so if like most people smoke weed
you know regularly or occasionally no
one cares about that other than that you
don't really see
a proliferation not in the goth scene
really like you said like kind of like
you know like molly or
things like that i know a couple people
that do that sometimes but
not really you don't really see a lot of
it honestly
the only thing [ __ ] man you don't even
see that many like goths anymore that
smoke yeah
i know maybe and then vaping they all
started vaping like me and then they
stopped and then they stopped vaping
because you don't need to vape
i know i out of our friends i think i
remember like two people that still
smoke cigarettes
and that's it yeah i mean that's it but
it's it's
not a drug scene really i mean
i think really what's replacing a lot of
those drugs is social media social media
i think has replaced a lot of drugs
they're getting their endorphin highs
from [ __ ] posting pictures
well people have more options they have
like other things to do because i do
kind of feel like a lot of times you got
into drugs because
what the [ __ ] else was there to do
especially if you grew up in like some
shitty town you couldn't go any place it
was a rite of passage to get into a
scene of friends sure a lot of it had to
do and nowadays you don't really have to
do that anymore and no one cares
like it's not necessarily cool or uncool
like no one really gives a [ __ ] about it
anymore which i think is good i think
that's like a much healthier way of
looking at it yeah if you want to do it
fine if you don't want to do it also
fine no one's going to like [ __ ] on you
about it here in the united states you
had to be 21 to drink alcohol and well
me growing up in brazil
there was no there was a drinking age i
think it might have been about 16 or 18
but even that wasn't enforced
everybody's drinking but they weren't
drinking in excess because that what
because drinking was not seen as any
form of liberation or any form of like
well i'm an adult now or there was no
yeah there's no there was no taboo
against it
i mean little kids
grow up drinking wine at the dinner
table in brazil they don't give a [ __ ]
about that and beer is considered oh
beer has alcohol in it they you know
that's the kind of the [ __ ]
beer has alcohol in it yeah it's like
you know they wouldn't even know beer
was just
it was there i mean not much it doesn't
much
so people make a big deal out of [ __ ] i
honestly i don't think i've ever drunk
enough beer to get drunk in my life i
would fall asleep
before i drank enough beer together
than anything else that too yeah beer
just makes me very very sleepy
thank you it's bad too well yeah i'm not
a big fan of beer like liquid bread i
like some of it like i like kind of
coffee stouts i like that kind of stuff
um but i'm not like like a big beer
connoisseur like i said i've drunk it
times when you know we were at a place
that didn't have a liquor license so all
they had was beer and wine so you know
i'll have a couple then but it's just
kind of like it just mostly makes me
sleepy and just makes me want to pee a
lot so i'm sure was that the ice maker
noise no i got a guy downstairs working
on the front lawn yeah i've had guys in
and out working on dave's sprinkles
though the landscapers are here the
sprinklers were kind of
broken and like somebody's fixing that
so yeah if you hear noises it's it's
work man
we have like work met at that we're here
all week yeah
once the sale went through then i
started to like you know worry about
what the house looked like on the
outside and the landscaping was [ __ ]
up
it was a bit yeah i mean not terrible
but i turned it down sprinklers on
[ __ ] today and noticed that there was
a damn leak coming out and they went
down there and found the leak and got it
out well that wasn't the guy just here
last week yeah but the thing is is that
it took a while because because the
people that lived here before weren't
running it on a road regular basis
so you know it was that was that was
something we missed
there was a small leak there it was in a
t-joint i saw it was spraying out of
there high pressure
didn't cost us anything though
well but no it cost me a hundred bucks
to have him fix that but
i found out that that's not bad though i
found out that our water meter doesn't
seem to be working
hmm
yeah we were sitting there watching and
it was like that thing's not right the
leak wasn't registering
so next like don't tell anybody next
time next time i run that water the
water sprinkler system i'm gonna sit
there and watch that thing let's just
pretend that we didn't and see if it see
if it's actually
registering water because i have two
sources of water i got
drinking water comes from one source and
then the landscape water to water this
this this lawn this lawn is almost an
acre so i got a big sprinkler system
i'm gonna put a big ass [ __ ] garden
in the back it's going to look like a
decorative garden
and you need some privacy a lot of the
trees and a lot of the plants in that
garden will yield because the i mean the
backyard is big but it's open like an
open line the next house is far away
down there right yeah but it's all open
up to that and i don't and i don't love
that i don't want to put some fruit
trees i want to put a avocado tree out
there ooh that would be nice yeah i'm
gonna put tomato plants but i'm gonna
have it yeah let's have them i'm gonna
have them in areas
that look decorative so i don't want it
to look like my grandparents [ __ ]
you know mississippi sharecropping
[ __ ]
shotgun house yeah you wanted to roast
the corn and all that [ __ ] now i'm gonna
have it nice
functional but nice yeah it's gonna look
like but also aesthetic decorative
garden but you'll be able to go out
there and eat
see that would be nice yeah
yeah we could we could have some citrus
trees
pumpkins some pumpkins watermelons yeah
[ __ ] those are tomatoes yeah pumpkins
and watermelons are very very easy
they're just easy to grow very easy
um tomatoes also pretty easy to grow
avocado trees i'll put avocado that
would be lovely that would be like get
one it's already kind of grown and have
it put buy it and grow it up yeah you
can just go to like [ __ ] home depot
and [ __ ] like that man
trees in a couple years or go to that
nursery up where
uh down the street from where we used to
live what was that place called there
was this big massive nursery that was
like right on there we went there and
got sawed one time i can't remember what
it was called yeah i'm gonna have it so
you can walk through it and i'll have
stones and
benches and [ __ ]
i'll probably put some solar lights
yeah why not
i'll eat them
don't eat the koi not the koi but i'll
put fish in there you can eat them
yeah yeah i wonder if well the hoa might
be like you can't put a pond in your
backyard you can't get off you can't you
might be able to you can put a pond back
there
well it's got to be decorative you know
the water waterfalls and little
fountains and [ __ ] you know and you can
put
fish in there and eat them
it doesn't have to be deep you don't
have to be a foot deep
it's like i just feel through the
alligators show up they got an alligator
that's what i mean i don't want like
[ __ ] alligators and then beijing goes
out on the back porch and she's like
pookie doesn't go outside so i'm happy
bull frogs
still likes to go sit on the back porch
and like [ __ ] around the house sometimes
and i just like so i kind of worry about
her but
you know
um
let's see where was i
cheryl says i sold weed for years before
it was legal how don't think i haven't
thought about like [ __ ] selling that
[ __ ] for some extra money
um
campus says i'll super chat 50 if you if
you go open a door and yell amigra at
the at the landscape those white dudes
they wouldn't even know what that is
it's white
my landscapers are anglo-american
uh granters also said several classmates
from trenton high class of 87 have died
in recent years diabetes covid colon
cancer couples suicides grant their
students yeah i don't see it
uh it's pretty far out well yeah because
i was i'm trying to like answer people's
questions
um
actually yeah [ __ ] man i got a message
from my mom the other day and she said
almost all of my
mom's side of my family has covened
so
and no uh lsd does not act like truth
serum
no it's yeah it's a whole different vibe
it's it's a whole different vibe it's
really really hard to explain i was
trying to explain it to a friend of ours
who wanted to do it but hadn't done it
and so i told her i said well if i do it
i'll call you
and try to like talk you through what
it's like
but
it's really it's hard to describe out of
them all it's the best one i've tried it
it's really hard to describe it i've
tried them all and i would say let's do
it it's not like being drunk no it's not
like being
it's not like weed it's not like i don't
know it's different it's not like
morphine it's not like it's its own
thing yeah it's it's a totally totally
different sensation
i liked it though i really really feel
totally coherent
totally coherent
i remember everything i said on it i
remember everything i felt on it i
remember everything yeah you can drive
on it if you're disciplined i wouldn't
me and steve rouse used to drive on it
in high school because i tried to type
on my laptop and my laptop kept going
like that and i'm just like well god
damn it you have to
you have visual hallucinations but you
don't right but you don't believe them
yeah you know it's not real no it's not
real but it is kind of when i was trying
to type on my computer i was like well
this is uh frustrating
i knew that it wasn't really doing that
yeah like i know my laptop isn't
breathing yeah but you see things but
it's mostly in your mind and you know it
yeah you know
um just
to me i never i thought it was just it's
just a man i don't want to sit here and
endorse these damn drugs
that that's it's a hard one to find you
have to have good connections nowadays
because it's not not quite a money maker
lsd doesn't have a long shelf life uh
it's uh not a street drug anymore
so you have to know people that can make
it
uh
or you have to know people that know
people that can make it
yeah and blotter it's comes on paper and
some of the stuff that adheres it and
fixes it to the paper may not be all
that good for you
so really the best way to go is [ __ ]
liquids which is like
lsd 25 but it has a very short shelf
life
usually that comes out of universities
university biochemistry departments
so uh and some people just know how to
make it too but like i said it's not
streetable
you know
if you guys think that rich people don't
do drugs you're [ __ ] tripping all
those private islands and all those
[ __ ] yachts that have billionaires on
them they don't follow any of those drug
laws they go everywhere they need to go
they don't go through customs or
anything
and they have [ __ ] whole 55-gallon
[ __ ] barrels full of [ __ ] exotic
custom-made drugs that are made in their
chemical plants
when they went to [ __ ] uh epstein's
island
there's a there was a whole support
network you can see it
they showed it in the for the video
drone or the video uh
the drone footage
they had a um
kind of a support maintenance area and
in there they had
50 gallon drums
of chemicals that were not illegal they
were legal
and they were made at jeffrey epstein's
um
drug manufacturing facilities that he
had because he made pharmaceuticals also
or knew people that made pharmaceuticals
and they said that one of the things
that that was in there
was a cocaine analog that you could
snort and it felt like cocaine
but it chemically it wasn't
so it would fail a cocaine
test if you were to test it for cocaine
and one of the things that was weird
about it
is that
it was engineered where you could snort
it and get the effects of cocaine until
you reached a certain point like it
might be good for a day
but eventually you started snorting it
and the chem and it would do something
to your nervous system to to make you
nauseated
and so you would reject it you wouldn't
get high on it you go yeah
it was like a clockwork orange situation
it was like a clock
the situation was they were making it
was a cocaine analog that had a safety
in it right they would prevent you from
what seems pretty smart
it prevented you from becoming addicted
to it
so you really loved it until built up
into your system and your nervous system
would start to reject it they always
landed and you go i don't want that i
don't want that and you couldn't snort
it for another couple days
after that
but they had other ones that they would
go to that's the only one i remembered i
think there were two other ones they
were analogs of other drugs so they
would hand them out at parties and
they'd have fun with them and then i
don't want that one anymore and then
move on to another one and they will you
couldn't get addicted to any of them
and they didn't have any street names
they were just something that they were
making in their own personal
laboratories where they make
pharmaceuticals because they're in the
medical industry they own medical
industry stuff
so there's [ __ ] out there that never hit
the street
only billionaires and friends of
billionaires [ __ ] know about it and
they don't even sell it they just give
it to one another
cheryl says there's a hippie town an
hour from here you can find all kinds of
psychedelics pretty easy yeah uh oscar
says lawyers love coke yeah i've heard
i've heard that um granthar said steve
had a buddy named mike grifford grifford
yeah who did 10 years in the pen for
cooking up some new version of ketamine
at the university of michigan chem lab
yeah yeah well we're talking about the
same people bro
all kinds of weird [ __ ] happened
at that [ __ ] at the university chemical
man you get me to say this [ __ ] on
youtube
but that's common knowledge in law
enforcement
a lot of these exotic drugs come from
university chemistry laboratories and
the guys that come they can make all the
and there's no way to control it uh
controlling things like drugs and guns
and [ __ ] all these things that people
think are taboo it's a [ __ ] losing
battle you'll never win that
uh the best thing to do is to legalize
all that stuff and control it and try to
regulate it to keep it out of the hands
of kids and to let people understand
what the effects of this stuff uh is and
what and the bad things it can do to you
if you uh
if you take too much of it people have
to be confronted with excess
the problem is is that there are a lot
of people that are sub 100 iq people in
the world and if you put them in contact
with the some of these substances they
kill themselves with it
okay well
there are always evolutionary
bottlenecks
there are people that don't exist
anymore because they could not really
survive in a world that had gin in it
okay
but distillation has been around for
over 100 years now almost 200 years
distillation is not killing people at
the rate that it did back in the 1700s
okay
uh
it's best if you let the human race come
in contact with things
that may challenge them
to help strengthen the human race that's
that's the way i want it let's say if
not then there's no progress
distillation was a problem in the 1700s
but why in the 1700s it's not really a
problem now
because the people that were susceptible
to distilled alcohol that would destroy
themselves in the face of distilled
alcohol they're not as numerous as they
used to be and the first one was gin
gin was the crack of the 1700s they
thought it was the end of the world
that jinn existed
and i don't see people killing each
other [ __ ] machine guns at the street
over jen do you
that would be really weird if you saw
that yeah yeah
those problems [ __ ] go away with time
and people just gonna have to realize
that you can't control everything you
have to let nature take its course
we see things from the viewpoint of
governments and religions and ideology
and all reality does not things don't
work if you look at reality through the
lens of government
religions and ideology
nature does what it wants to do
no matter what you think of it
you just can't control things not for
long
danny rolling ghostface says the effects
of lsd is like dreaming while awake with
heightened sight and sound senses
it is kind of like that better though
but yeah it's better in the sense that
you're very cause you know when you have
dreams it's always kind of like
scattered and like all over the place
whereas on lsd you have the best of that
but you also are really like hyper aware
yeah of everything and having out of
body experience well and like i said one
thing that i liked about it it made
everything like even mundane things
look really beautiful yeah like oh my
god the texture of this wall
you know it's like oh my god the you
know we said we had um
like the tv had turned itself on and it
had like that uh you know the screen
saver type thing and we went up there
and looked at it and it was just these
gorgeous like swirling colors and we
were talking about like how beautiful it
was so it makes everything look like
really really
beautiful yeah and it made me feel like
i said it made me feel like everything
was like okay
you know what i mean you get a feeling
of well-being yeah and and uh it's all
in your mind and you know what's in your
mind and you don't care about it
um it's it's it's it's a good one uh the
the smarter you the smarter you are the
more pleasant it will be for you
the dumber you are the more horrifying
it will be notice that because
i've just seen it i've seen it
personally personally um
people who are kind of dumb can't handle
it because they think that they're going
[ __ ] crazy they can't rationalize
their way out of it they try to control
it and that's not what you do you're
supposed to just go with it you can't
yeah i mean that's why i wanted to try
it because you know as a creative person
i said i want to make another one i you
know i wanted to see what it was like i
said i wanted to maybe like open up some
perception or something like that it's
like i wanted to think of some [ __ ] i
didn't think of before so i went into it
with a very positive
mindset which might have
uh influenced why i enjoyed myself so
much on it because it just seemed like a
very very positive experience like it
made me feel like oh man everything's
like so awesome and you know everything
looks so awesome and everything's like
beautiful and connected and stuff like
that and i was like oh my god no i sound
like a grateful dead fan oh [ __ ]
you know what i mean and i was like kind
of aware that i was thinking i was like
oh yeah okay see now now i know what
they're what they're talking about i
said now i know what all the hippies are
talking about when they're talking about
everything's connected man it does like
kind of feel like that
but not in a hippie dippy way it's
actually like kind of a cool like
profound sort of way you know i don't
know
um
cheryl says cocaine sucks like going to
the dentist um
i've only done it once and it didn't
really i don't know
it wasn't right snickers is so awesome i
know it's just sitting there oh is this
or is this the coconut oh it's coconut
so i had a screwdriver because i was
finishing up the last of the plane vodka
but he went today and got coconut vodka
yeah this is coconut vodka and you got
pineapple juice
like a g
so we got kind of like a pina colada
pina colada action going on here
jenny's a hippie and that's the thing
it's like
i was like really aware like as it was
going on i'm like oh my god i sound like
a dirty hippie it's like i hate that but
i was like i get it though i get like
why they're like that
i never like wanted to go follow the
grateful dead around because [ __ ] that
but because that's like some lame-ass
[ __ ]
uh if an older someone wanted to
experiment do you recommend taking lsd
with a group of people or alone um don't
take it alone uh especially if you've
never done it before
um because you don't know how it's gonna
go
it's always better to have at least one
other person doesn't necessarily have to
be a bunch of people but uh have at
least one other person there that's done
it before
preferably multiple times
and if something goes wrong
or if you start freaking out or
something like that they will be able to
like talk you down from it um
i'll also i don't advise going anywhere
like the first time you do it don't go
any place that's not your house like the
first time i did it it's like it was me
and tom and he's like okay we're gonna
do it in the house
and
he's like because i gotta watch you just
you know because you don't know like you
don't know how it's gonna affect that
person you don't know if that person's
gonna be like whoa i'm gonna tear off my
clothes and go like run down the street
okay so not everyone's gonna do that but
some people might uh so you have to
kind of regulate it
so
regularly would you regulate nose um
somebody like jeffy art asked uh
if you've never done it before do you
advise doing it by yourself or doing it
with a group of people no and that's
what i said it's like you should have at
least one person that's done it before
like multiple times that can
help you out if you don't go anywhere
you stay at home that's what i said
don't yeah don't go anyplace on it if
you've never done it before um
especially because you don't like i
didn't do anything crazy but at one
point i did try to leave the house i
well i wasn't gonna leave the house yeah
i thought well i didn't think i was a
werewolf yeah
i knew i wasn't a werewolf you wanted to
act like a werewolf but i wanted to act
like a werewolf and i said i'm going to
go out in the backyard and roll around
in the grass
like a werewolf would i guess and uh no
no no you're not going and tom's like no
no you're not let's do something else
let's watch some david bowie videos or
something like that you know what i mean
so he had to like you know
and david but he's talking to me dear
man yeah i remember back in the 70s
he's like
he's talking to me across time he's
talking to me yeah i'm like oh my god he
totally is but i know it's all
hallucinating yeah you know he's not
yeah really but you're kind of it's
almost kind of like you're playing into
it just yeah
that's why it's hard to explain you know
it's not real but you're just playing
into the fantasy doorbell rang and me
and jenny rant
and hi
oh my god that was so [ __ ] funny it's
the mailman
and i know the mailman
so i go i'm gonna see what he wants we
were freaking out we didn't know who it
was the door and we were like oh [ __ ]
yeah man it's like tuesday afternoon or
something we were both off work he goes
hey he goes hey you know mr ross got a
package and i go okay hold on i gotta
sign for it right here on the tennis
okay hold on it's time for it and i went
dude i'm really [ __ ] up on lsd right
now he's like i'm because you are
because yeah i'm high as [ __ ] balls
it's gonna be all right man just sign
[Laughter]
he's laughing
well
i remember what happened when the
doorbell rang
the first thing i thought was is that
the cops and then tom's like [ __ ] and i
was like [ __ ] and we ran into we ran
into the walk-in closet and i said we
gotta look and see who it is because
there was a window in our walk-in closet
at the old house yeah but you but it was
too high up like and you couldn't really
see mailman
and then he was like it's the mailman
i'm like what do we do and then we're
like in closet then i was like oh my god
this is like ridiculous like i knew it
was ridiculous but we were still kind of
like freaking out at the same time
and i was like go to the door i gotta
see what he wants yeah and so like he
goes to the door and yeah he just told
the person he's like dude i'm high as
balls right yeah i'm tripping balls and
the dude was like he's like oh okay all
right like i said it was like tuesday
afternoon i was off work that day
and he's like we're get because we had
bought the lsd like a couple weeks
before and he's like he's like oh you're
off we're oh we're doing this today and
i was just like okay because we didn't
have anywhere to go
so it's like i'm sure that mailman
probably still tells that story
he's like tuesday afternoon and these
two [ __ ] people were like high as
balls running around their house like
pretending they were werewolves holy
[ __ ]
it was fun though
[Music]
five stars would do again
i'm on here didn't get the answer to his
question earlier wait what i didn't see
the answer what was it what was the
question
um
do it with a close friend only not
around a group of family ever yeah yeah
just do it with somebody that's done it
a bunch of times before and look at
yourself in the mirror too long oh yeah
that's enough focus on anything too long
that's another thing yeah
yeah
don't look at yourself it's i did but it
not for a long time but a lot of people
like look at themselves in the mirror
and they look like all distorted and
that upsets us you're not as long as
you're not um
uptight or worried or scared you'll have
a pleasant experience go into it you got
to be positive go into it being like
this is going to be awesome yeah what
you do is you take the blotter that take
the blotter and cut it in half first and
take that and wait 45 minutes for that
yeah you got to take a while and you go
oh okay i see what this is and then you
can take the rest and then take the rest
of it yeah yeah um he said something
about
uh i don't know cocaine was always not
for me it bored me um
i'm not into stimulants i'll drink
coffee once in a while and that's enough
for me
yeah i'm not well yeah that's not a
question but yeah what well that was
just like something
yeah i'm not super like i don't need
stimulants i'm spazzy enough as it is i
need like [ __ ] that's gonna like [ __ ]
chill me out you know what i'm saying
that's why i was upset that like the few
times i tried weed and i was like i
thought this was supposed to like mellow
me out this is like totally not working
but i would never [ __ ] smoke crack
because crack is [ __ ] that would get
a grip in you all right you just see a
rock head you're like [ __ ] man he's all
[ __ ] up but um
uh old powdered cocaine from back in the
day was great
at
um waking you back up
you're at a party and you're just been
drinking too [ __ ] much you're getting
ready to pass out [ __ ] you just
[ __ ] snort a couple lines and you're
it's totally sober
it just counteracts it counteracts the
counteracts the alcohol and you can go
right back to drinking we used to do
that
yeah i don't think i need that either
when it starts to wear off he starts to
crash though you're like
but i especially couldn't do like [ __ ]
my my old ass is almost 50 years old i
don't think i could well as it is now
late 20s
now when we do the show and we drink on
the show if i have like two or three
drinks it's going to take me like a day
and a half to recover like i can still
do [ __ ] like i can still function but
i'm like god damn i'm so [ __ ] tired
and i'm like dragon ass but you know
it's that's just happens when you're
when you get older i guess yeah uh the
question was oh i asked what your
opinion is on methadone
oh methadone any [ __ ] junkie that i
knew was on methadone was [ __ ] up just
as much by the methadone as they were
for the [ __ ] heroin
yeah i don't well i i lived in the uk at
the time when and and i'm not saying i
think it's better
to
uh you know if you have heroin addicts
or something like that they at least put
them in a tree they didn't put them in
prison they at least like put them in a
treatment program
and
tried to you know tried to wean them off
of the [ __ ]
and it's about money man i would never
have given those dudes methadone you're
never done making smoke opium
opium would have alleviated a lot of a
lot of the problems and opium is a lot
more manageable than heroin a lot more
you can smoke opium and walk away from
it
i never smoked opium although oh that's
another one i'm more into like i said
i'm more into like mellowing out
hallucinogenics it's not i don't want i
don't need [ __ ] that like makes me more
spazzy or more anxious i don't need that
all that opium and heroin [ __ ] it's more
about [ __ ] falling asleep and
becoming nothing and doing nothing and
no it's like anesthesia
i never really saw them
i never really saw the uh
well i could understand that being hit
by a foot if you were to inject heroin
you'd be hit by a wave of heaven but you
wouldn't do anything you just sit there
you know well yeah that's what a lot of
them do they just they just kind of like
lay it around what's a lot which from
their their point of view they're
probably having a good time but from
everyone else's point of view like get
off your bomb yeah get up
[Laughter]
um but
like when i was in egypt we'd sit sit
out there [ __ ] and [ __ ] dah hob
out and [ __ ] sinai peninsula
they'd be pumping out jimi hendrix and
[ __ ] pink floyd and [ __ ]
and you sit there with a hookah and you
smoke opium which is a nice freaking
smoke it's very a heavy
oily
smoke
you don't cough it you don't cough even
if you're not a smoker it immediately
just anesthetizes your lungs you don't
cough it
back up and it's just kind of like
liquid grapes it's got a nice
it's a very nice tobacco
well see now that sounds really really
delightful and i would put its power
about about there with alcohol
so very easy to control
um and then eventually you'll kind of
fall asleep and you wake up you just
feel satisfied and just walk off it's
not like oh i gotta have more of that
it's you know it's kind of like you're
satisfied
and it's not like alcohol where you wake
up being like what the [ __ ] did i do
oh no
no hangover or anything just real
[ __ ] like i have dry mouth and i feel
kind of nauseated and a headache no just
really [ __ ] restful
sleep you know see i like the sound of
that yeah
actually i can't
understand why alcohol would be legal
but
but opium wouldn't see that's very weird
about the same i mean to me it seems
like you're either going to legalize all
that it should be like all or nothing
because
i mean look we like out we like our
alcohol you know that but
you know there's other drugs that it
seems like the effects of them are less
are either the same as alcohol or even
like less
you know less
and
and yet those drugs are still illegal
yeah
which seems very yeah it is it's very
silly you can't have opium in say like
the middle east or you can't have
alcohol in certain middle eastern
countries
you know like egypt didn't like
distilled alcohol you could have wine
and beer but they didn't like whiskeys
that was like illegal we were smoking we
were drinking them anyway
you know well yeah i mean [ __ ] that we
were the cops in that area well if you
had money over this just like everything
else in the middle east people have
money like always like [ __ ] skirt the
laws yeah so if you were to well they're
partying on compounds there's no law
enforcement they're in these palaces and
compounds
they just don't want it in public
um
but
you
by law rarely say like in saudi arabia
we have some we have some listeners and
i have some friends in saudi arabia you
know saab probably listening now he's
never listening live he'll listen later
on a couple days from now
but uh sadie's doctor in saudi arabia
and uh
alcohol
is illegal
but i bet you
i bet you um
you could get in trouble with it if you
got caught with it but last i heard
they're all drinking they're drinking on
those compounds they got private
discotheques inside their [ __ ]
compounds which is like a
some of those rich saudi dudes you know
what i mean they have a nightclub in
their house
and they're not telling what's going on
in there
they can't party in public so they do it
in private
and they import foreign women to show up
and then their own women and dudes and
they have a whole western
scene going on in somebody's [ __ ]
palace
well they'll have alcohol in there but
that's a big problem but like i said
there's no law enforcement agents they
own the law
you know
and i guess
because it's not happening in public
they're not as [ __ ] strict about it
they just don't want it in public yeah
um
but then i bet you if you looked it
probably something like opium is
probably not a problem at all
well i kind of it wasn't in egypt i mean
in a lot of ways i kind of feel like
trying to crack down on
you know any kind of any kind of quote
unquote personal bliss yeah whether
people want to drink themselves into
oblivion or if they want to do opium or
whatever i kind of feel like you're
really like shooting yourself in the
dick there because people are going to
do it no matter what you do no matter
what you say
i think it's better
to acknowledge
that people have a right to that yeah
and just try to like regulate it make
sure like little kids don't get it you
don't want people driving on the [ __ ]
you don't want people giving it to their
babies or whatever but you know
just have like some guidelines
but other than that if people want to
live alone and they want to get like
completely [ __ ] [ __ ] up on whatever
their uh you know chemical of choice is
i don't honestly have a problem with
that i really don't
well um
you're not hurting it as long as you're
not hurting anybody else what happened
what happened over the years especially
in the 20th century around the time of
the 60s
the 60s you had a damn culture
war that happened
and uh the republicans and the democrats
started to diverge
and what was strange is that the
republicans
who originally
would have supported something like
personal human rights about
right to bliss
they turned against it
saying that it was like harm prevention
like we got to keep these people from
following they hooked up with the with
the christian
right that's kind of why and he had
religion and harm prevention happening
with the republicans
and they started the war on drugs later
on in the 80s which was even the dea at
that time was like no no no i mean you
don't want to do that that's not the way
to go about it recreate prohibition yep
how'd that work out not so good yeah not
so good but that's all going away now
and a lot of that had to do with boomers
uh boomer republicans and their parents
tended to be religious
and uh they were anti-drug
mostly just because of religious
purposes it didn't really have anything
to do with logic or reason uh it didn't
have anything to do with [ __ ]
constitutional rights
now they got rid of the right to bliss
in the late 1800s because half the
country was jacked up on cocaine the
other half was [ __ ] up on morphine but
that was the 1800s it's a very different
population now
uh 1800s they had didn't had no idea
what the effects of these drugs were
they were kind of not taking an educated
choices
yeah that's just
the people were kind of in a childlike
state i mean at least people now have
the information you know what they are
at their fingers right if you get into
it right
then at least you know what you're
getting into i consider myself to be a
modern republican i'm i'm secular all
right i don't believe in any of that
[ __ ] boomer style republican i
believe in the old republican stuff
traditional stuff which is
human rights
by the [ __ ] constitution
and yeah some people are going to get
hurt but this is not a child proof world
you have the i'm more of like a
libertarian
more you know
some of the [ __ ] the republicans did i
was like well why the [ __ ] are they
doing that that's stupid
i mean
i remember being a kid
loving [ __ ] heavy metal and [ __ ] and
heavy metal was [ __ ] republican as
[ __ ] but
gener
generation x didn't see it the same way
you'd have your republican parents come
and [ __ ] tear you down heavy metal
posters up for some [ __ ] crazy reason
like what the [ __ ] you said your stepdad
did yeah he came in there and [ __ ]
[ __ ] and this and that a good yeah my
grandpa did tearing up the damn judas
priest poster talking about duran
[Laughter]
so man even back in the 80s my grandpa
was i was like you know what no one
cares if they're gay or not i was in the
this was the 80s and i was kind of like
it's like are they straight are they gay
who gives a [ __ ] right i don't give a
[ __ ] a lot of they look good and the
music is good a lot of young modern
democrats are having a hard time
understanding [ __ ] what
what [ __ ] generation x republicans
and younger are about the old boomers
are they they're more and more
irrelevant okay
the uh the the right and the left has a
lot more in common now with our generous
than they used to a lot of the division
is artificial you got
you got political parties that are
trying to win they don't care what
reality is they're going to put a
[ __ ]
wedge in between
groups
because it's it's a war between coke and
pepsi basically
and this [ __ ] is going [ __ ] sideways
as [ __ ]
but in the end i believe it will kind of
work out because people are going to
realize that
political parties in general are full of
[ __ ]
they're full of [ __ ] and if you [ __ ]
they'll kill you
to gain power
got to go back to [ __ ] traditions
and [ __ ] [ __ ] that actually works and
things that survive contacts with
reality which is [ __ ] that's very
practical
if it's not practical it's not gonna
work
war on drugs big big [ __ ] mistake
i was in [ __ ]
service during the first first gulf war
and that seemed to be i thought islam
might have been a [ __ ] serious threat
uh well it became an even bigger threat
once you start [ __ ]
doing what they're doing you know uh
the [ __ ] that they were doing in the
middle east didn't have anything to do
with islam it's about making money
uh then then fueling a war machine and a
bunch of [ __ ] corporations yeah duh
that same war machine is going to be
used against the united states now
and american citizens all right this
empire is going sideways as [ __ ]
people will wake up to it though
eventually they'll wake up to that we're
being lied to [ __ ] my liberal ass woke
up to that like a long time ago where
you been there's not gonna be
there's not gonna be the reality that
people think there's gonna be we'll see
what's gonna happen
i've always been of the opinion look
leave people alone if what you're doing
okay
if you want to do
any whatever drugs
you can sleep with whoever you want it
doesn't really matter i mean
obviously if they're consenting let's
let's all get concerned they got to be
adults well yeah let's not do the kid
thing that's [ __ ] up and no animals
either come on yeah uh because you can't
animals can't get that so as long as
everyone's consenting adults do whatever
the [ __ ] you want
[ __ ] all over each other i don't give a
[ __ ] it's gross i don't want to see it
but you know whatever
um whatever drugs you want to do
honestly
all that [ __ ] i am into legalize drugs
legalize prostitution legalize all that
stuff regulate it sure
um you know make sure there's laws
everyone's safe that's like traditional
america that's what i'm saying and it's
like i kind of feel like that's a better
way to go about things it's not going to
be because if you
like you said when we had the with the
whole situation with prohibition look
how that turned out yeah uh
in case you are not from here
prohibition that's kind of like what
made the mob so powerful yeah there's an
equal and opposite reaction
when you ban things you're just
empowering organized crime yeah you ban
alcohol organize crime ban guns organize
crime ban [ __ ] sex organize crime it
will [ __ ] continue
because something will always like flow
in to fill in the gap filling in that
gap now here's the thing the same
[ __ ] ruling class that backs the
banning of these things are the same
ruling class that will invest in the
criminal side of that
just like they do in mexico well because
no they don't really believe in any they
don't believe it they're just kind of
making money well yeah they're just kind
of like well you know we don't want the
plebes doing that right
um you know you guys should think it's
bad to do drugs or be gay or whatever
the [ __ ] just like the mexican mob and
all these hotels but we're gonna do
whatever
because we have money and no one's gonna
like call us out on it the mexican mob
and the mexican cartels if you actually
trace the money and see who's running
those it's the elected officials of
[ __ ] mexico
because if you [ __ ] make something
illegal you've now
made a potential market to make money on
so you play both sides these people are
not [ __ ] moral
they don't actually believe in what
they're saying they see you as a sucker
just like the people who [ __ ] banned
alcohol the same people that banned
alcohol in the united states also
[ __ ] invested in bootlegging
and then they invested in in making
prisons and law enforcement that's what
i mean by they're doing both sides they
don't have any principles there's no
principle no no
no so you want to get back and if you're
an american you want to get back to what
the original
[ __ ] america was which was you had a
right to bliss you had a right to over
your own body which means you could be a
prostitute you could be a gunfighter you
could challenge somebody to a legal duel
which somebody's like what the what the
[ __ ] you talking about look as long as
you have as long as you have kind of
like uh you know an agreement an
agreement about it a legal framework for
that
right i don't really have a pro like i
said
as long as you're not hurting anybody
else right everybody's agreeing to the
situation that's happening
um you know do you two people do you
both sign off on a duel and all that
kind of [ __ ] the federal government you
can do that can draft an 18 year old boy
and send him to [ __ ] wage a war
against people he doesn't even know
so the ruling class can make money off
of that
who are they to say that that same 18
year old boy can't challenge another 18
year old boy to a duel when they both
want to fight each other to begin with
to settle this issue outside the court
of law you got a corporate war and a
private war it's the same thing
if you tell him he can't do that who are
you to tell him that he must fight your
war
he says you're going to fight our war
but you can't fight your own
no no no
that's [ __ ]
that's [ __ ] crazy as [ __ ]
dueling in the united states got banned
basically de facto was never truly
adjudicated
it just changed because
a new generation came into power
and they went our dads they were
[ __ ] uh you can't duel
no it's a human right's a duel
but you have to understand what the
rules of dueling were
you could challenge you due to a duel
if you didn't accept a challenge you
couldn't kill him
you could only say
he pushed out he didn't accept the chair
and then that was the end of it that was
the end of it
if he accepted the duel
then there's a whole framework illegal
framework together i don't have a
problem with that no you had presidents
that were doing jackson i think killed
killed two in duels i think insulting
his wife and another one as i said as
long as every look as long as everyone's
adults
willingly and they are agreeing to all
the terms everyone's agreeing to all the
terms
you're an adult you're not mentally
impaired in any way you're right um you
agreed to do that right then
that's on you and you see it after that
it acted as a [ __ ] um as a pressure
relief valve for [ __ ] running
their mouth too [ __ ] much
guy's running his mouth he's running his
mouth with [ __ ] i challenge you to a
duel
and he put up her shut up yeah put up a
shut up
no i don't want to do you see he's a
[ __ ]
shut your [ __ ] mouth
you know he i challenged him and he's
[ __ ] still going he doesn't want to
do it
okay he's a [ __ ]
anything that would make people shut up
is a good thing right right
and then everybody has to go you do you
talking you talking [ __ ] he challenged
you
and you didn't accept his challenge
you're still talking [ __ ] but you won't
fight him
so you know what i mean yeah so everyone
can ignore you yeah you're
we got you on block
you know it has to be
legal ways where citizens these are
citizens okay which the the concept of
citizenship seems to be going away from
[ __ ] people a citizen had rights and
a citizen one of the rights was a
citizen to keep other citizens in check
legally yeah you could sue someone but
you could also agree to this fight you
know let's fight
and here's the thing that goes all the
way back to europe and the honky
motherland they were doing that in the
medieval areas era and they were
settling disputes between men and women
that way
they'd have a man or woman in a divorce
in a divorce dispute challenging each
other to a duel and i remember that yeah
yeah they would challenge the other to
the duels
and you know [ __ ] they would give the
woman a handicap they did different ways
what they put in a hole or something no
they put the man in the hole they put
the man in the hole that's right the man
in the hole and the woman was on top
that way the fight was more equal
so everyone could equally lose let me go
the reason
yeah i know i gotta go too but yeah
tammy says have you seen the movie
lawless with tom hardy i have not but
i'm gonna write that down right now
because
we love tom hardy
about moonshiners okay i'm gonna write
that down
we'll fight we'll watch that i promise
yeah i mean
like i said
me and tom we have uh
divergent political views let's put it
that way
but uh on that we can both agree um
honestly
as long as con as far as like control
over your own body goes uh this is why
i'm very i'm not pro-drug i'm just
saying that if people want to do drugs i
don't want to do drugs i'm just saying
like if people want to
and they're not hurting anyone else like
i said don't drive on it don't do do the
same thing that we do with like [ __ ]
dui
um i don't have a problem with it if you
want to be prostitutes i don't have a
problem with it as long as no one's
being forced into doing something they
don't want to do
as long as they are you know adult they
can give consent
i really do not have a problem with
anything pretty much that people want to
do
as long as everyone is consenting
and they're not hurting other people
that aren't
involved with whatever it is they're
doing um then you can just like do
whatever and everyone should stay out of
your goddamn business so you know
uh let's see
aerosmith wrote the song dude looks like
a lady after meeting vince neil from
motley crue
honestly it's so funny because
i remember like i said i grew up in the
70s and 80s
i was rolling a new wave
and everybody
picked on because when i was in junior
high
there was kind of like two
factions you had the new wave faction of
which i was apart and then you had the
heavy metal
which by that time was actually kind of
more
mainstream like heavy metal bon jovi
kind of [ __ ] motley crew kind of [ __ ]
by that point
so you had those two things
everybody picked on new waivers as being
quote unquote [ __ ]
even though
you make a good drink the people in the
[ __ ]
heavy metal bands looked way more girly
than the people in the new wave
it was all trans i mean come on
jesus christ
the dudes in duran duran because i was
really into duran duran was a kid
the dudes in duran duran
looked
a lot more like dudes than the dudes in
motley crew
just saying
um you know so i i don't know why
everyone was like ooh
new waves they're all [ __ ] blue blah
what the [ __ ] was that all about i don't
know
um let's see cheryl says something
similar happened to my
when i was 17 shared a joint with a
stranger had heroin in it
never did that again oh my god okay
my list must be so long which list my
my movie list it is
honestly sometimes and they keep adding
new [ __ ]
i went to shutter the other day well i
went to shutter yesterday because i've
you know i'm doing my folk horror thing
for february
and i went on there and watched two
movies yesterday that i'm that i
recorded reviews for
and they had added
like 10 new movies and i'm like god
[ __ ] damn it it's like
shudder
when do you expect me to watch all of
this stuff seriously
seriously
uh amanda gear says times are so bad now
like if you want drugs that aren't laced
with deadly [ __ ] it has to be grown
yourself or from a pharmacy
i mean
well it was the same thing back then i
mean honestly if you got drugs when like
back in the 80s and [ __ ] like that you
never knew what the hell was in there
all right can i go to the bathroom okay
good all right
you talking you still got plenty right
okay
yeah i'm good all right i'm good yeah i
made uh i'm on to the tequila
got that tequila going she got mad
because i touched her butt oh yeah she
doesn't want you touching her
she does the same thing i'll reach out
like this
see what everybody's saying
yeah sure saying that the uh
crew movie is hilarious yeah it was a
good movie though i liked it
uh lawless with tom hardy tom hardy's my
favorite actor everything he's in is
good i haven't seen that one though
and they're fighting over tom hardy
because i want tom hardy to be the next
double07
he'd be a great double 07. but evidently
uh
the the james bond people
they're like no we're not going to take
him which that's just [ __ ] stupid
that's [ __ ] stupid i mean he's a
no-brainer
for double-oh-seven
i guess they're saying well he's made
too many movies
yeah john [ __ ] duels kept people more
polite
we see
used to be that the uh traditional honky
motherland was built upon [ __ ] just
customs and traditions
uh with um
oh yeah
and they were honor based societies
people had honor okay
later on it started to get more
legalistic which is kind of a very
chinese kind of way of looking at things
um and modern society kind of has to
have both
but really legalism
i think better applies to like uh
merchantalism in other words kind of
like uh business law zoning and [ __ ]
like that you really need that
but when it comes to what we would call
criminal law
honor based honor based rules and
regulations traditions make more sense
to me so you have to have kind of a
both things happening at once
legalism
can come back and bite you in the ass
you want a legal society but you also
want it to to be slightly honor based
because your average person
actually operates upon a system of of of
honor not really a legal system all
right when dudes are in a bar fighting
they're not thinking about the laws
they're thinking about an honor based
system that some people would be like oh
that's terrible yeah but there's always
[ __ ] [ __ ] that are saying that you
need a mixture of it well honor based
works on a small smaller things
between individuals on a macro level
yeah yeah it's you need a more
complicated right because honestly to be
fair um
you know from an evolutionary standpoint
uh you know we're just basically evolved
monkeys yeah we're [ __ ] hairless so
we only evolved to be in a group of a
certain amount of people say up to 200.
larger than that we start having
problems right so you need some kind of
framework to address that so i think
you know in a large way we've done a
good job
as far as we can
you know do
of addressing
these weaknesses that we have yeah if
you want to call them weaknesses which
is how we are
i mean yeah i don't i don't use that
word in a judgmental term i'm just
saying that that's kind of like
you know from a naturalistic standpoint
that's just kind of like where you're
coming from with it do we have certain
uh limitations
you know
that's
i'm not being judgmental about that it's
just true every everybody every being
has
limitations you need to know what the
limitations are and we need to like work
to circumvent that or you know
if you look figure out how we're going
to work at the united states
in the uh 1800s
especially the the western territories
they have laws
but if you actually agree between the
lines
most of the laws were really focused
upon
things like uh
property rights
uh how certain things should be
conducted in in terms of you know what i
mean
whether somebody owned
mineral rights or water rights when it
went through they had lost
but the way the average people conducted
themselves on a daily day-to-day basis
was more along the lines of customs and
traditions all right
and uh which would be on what would be
an honor based assistant i would argue
that that is largely still the case it's
still pretty much i mean most people
when they go about just their daily life
99.99 of people right they're not
thinking about that they're just
thinking about i'm going about my day
and you're just trying to like go
through your day and like not make your
the day harder for other people i mean i
think i mean that's how i think i'm not
sure that's true and that's where some
of the problem comes in because you'll
have people that are doing what's
natural what they feel right at the time
and then somebody gets killed
and then next thing you know you're
thrown into a legal system that has a
totally different standard
that doesn't match up with reality
um it's too
uh it's too draconian
you got too many damn people in prison
a lot of them belong there okay but
there are some of them that don't uh
they're in in the united states each
state is slightly different and it's
going to be skewed based upon who those
voters are that are there which i think
that's great
because the united states is a damn
federal system it should go back to a
federalism where each state decides how
they're gonna run
run things and if you don't like it you
can leave
you can vote with your feet well if you
can afford to well anybody can afford to
move i mean [ __ ] i was [ __ ] moving
around the united states didn't have a
pot to piss in as a teenager
you can move
um
but like i said if you can't move then
you're forced to live in a place and you
don't like it then oh well
life isn't about fairness it's just
about practicality and what you can do
but you know nothing's going to be
perfect
to me
i look at entertainment and [ __ ]
i look at some of the entertainment's
good some of the entertainment is
[ __ ]
and i see some of the good [ __ ] that are
going like
yeah
a lot of america is basically moss
eisley spaceport and for star wars
and it's kind of always been that way
yeah it's really not any different yeah
to be honest it's not like that yeah
and honestly
i don't know that's why i'm kind of like
look i have enough problems with anxiety
okay it's like i don't want to be one of
those people and i especially
and i
thought this even when i was younger i
especially did not want to be one of
those old people
that just thought oh everything was
better back in my day blah blah blah i
was like jesus christ please kill me if
i ever get like that
honestly i would never
ever go back i missed some things about
the 70s and 80s but not enough to go
back to there no [ __ ] way well
technology i mean
nowadays it's god it's so much [ __ ]
better it's easier it's just so much
better everything is so much easier yeah
there's some [ __ ] nowadays i don't like
but
i wouldn't go back like back then jesus
christ what a pain in the ass everything
what we're talking about is just the
convenience of what a cell phone can do
and what a tablet can do with an
internet connection look at like look at
what things when i was young information
when i was younger
um
you know the only thing i ever wanted to
be
from the time i was a kid like
well a teenager i guess when i was a
little kid i wanted to be a vet until i
was like well i don't really want to
have to put like kitties and puppies to
sleep that would be a bummer and then
after i kind of like found out like i
kind of went down that road and then i
was like oh that i don't think i could
i'm too soft-hearted to do that
so i was like well all i ever wanted to
be was a horror writer
and for a long time in the 80s
you pretty much if you wanted to be a
successful horror writer you had to do
like what stephen king did you had to
like publish short stories and magazines
and then you had to have an agent and
then you had to go to like a big
publisher and you had to do all this
other kind of stuff
nowadays you don't have to do any of
that
you can publish your own book that looks
exactly the same as one from like a big
publisher and it has just as much chance
of like getting noticed maybe not just
as much chance because you don't have as
much advertising money behind you
but
it's out there anybody in the world can
like read that [ __ ] and to me like back
in the 80s if somebody had told me that
that was going to happen i'd have been
like thank [ __ ] god
you know
yeah that's all i i just wanted to like
write my [ __ ] and like
put my books out and like have people
read them and it's like that's like
[ __ ] awesome i never would have
imagined like how easy it was we
actually have a pretty good uh crowd
going right now this is open lines
people if you have any questions about
any of the damn uh cases that we've done
in the past if you have any questions go
ahead and drop in the comments section
and me and jenny will uh move the
conversation along those lines but we
can't just sit here all day long making
up these damn situations you all have to
be that needs
audience and interaction well i'm trying
to read some of the questions because
you keep talking uh tammy says have you
seen taboo with tom hardy i haven't ever
seen that one that [ __ ] made a
lot of movies god damn
there's so many movies okay yeah there's
i got to keep my i got to keep my [ __ ]
here
there's a lot of good movies tom hardy
did uh the other one he's awesome yeah
what was the one where he played the
british prisoner what was that that's
what they were talking about that was
the name of that movie beast no no
branson bronson brownstein yeah yeah
because cheryl just said tom hardy was
uh best as charles bronson and then lars
ulrich said was that charles bronson the
convict yes yeah yeah uh that movie oh
my god so good sophie sent us that right
yeah and it's kind of it's done in the
clockwork orange style yeah it's a
little bit it's a little bit surrealist
yeah a little bit you think it's you you
think it's kind of like stanley kubrick
doing this movie it is very kubricky
yeah in the clockwork style i'm kind of
into it because he is like something out
of clockwork orange
and uh yeah it was a great movie i
admired his uh this was great [ __ ]
i mean
and they're
they're seeing broccoli the broccoli
family is saying he cannot be bond
wait what
yeah
who do i need to hit
why can't he why couldn't he be james
bond he wants to be james bond and
they're telling him no why
i don't know they're [ __ ] [ __ ]
he'd be a great james bond yeah great
craig could be bonded i'm a fan of craig
i mean i could think of a lot of people
who would be a good james bond but he
would be a really good james bond i
think so maybe they're pretending
to decline on him because it's kind of a
no-brainer of course that's james
because you know how they do they're
just like oh we don't want it and then
he's like oh just surprisingly he was
surprised yeah
i think he'd be a great james bond he
would actually james bond has got to be
a badass white british dude because
that's what that character is you have
some people say well we want a black
james bond why the [ __ ] would you want
to black james bond
you got [ __ ]
you got
you got [ __ ] uh what's his name
[ __ ] uh a felix okay felix was black
twice
and i think and then the the the first
black felix what was his name
[ __ ] [ __ ] m007
felix what
felix lighter
the first black felix lighter was that
dude he's kind of reminded me of o.j
that big old dude and he's that was like
one of the best feet they should do a
spin-off series actually right if you
want to do a black james bond you don't
do james bond you do felix lighter okay
or or he needs his own shaft you know
shaft is [ __ ] the black james bond
even though
the shaft was it's not exactly the same
but it's similar it's similar okay he's
not british though but but neither was
he the slider felix lighter was he's
from the james bond universe but he was
american well he was cia wasn't cia yeah
that was the cies version and
most there were a couple of good felix
lighters that were white
uh but the two the two that were [ __ ]
two of them were black most of the white
ones were more kind of like the comedic
relief they were kind of clownish
a couple times feel that felix appears
and he's like the badass he's just like
james bond it's not quite i didn't
really think that worked because there's
been so many james bond movies
but the last
felix that died within the craig series
that was my favorite that was my
favorite felix slider of them all i
think he was the best one yeah i think
he was the best one he's been in a bunch
of movies here in the united states and
and i bought that character and [ __ ]
when he died and [ __ ] yeah i was like oh
man yeah that was a bummer but everybody
had to die everybody had to die because
they were wrapping up everybody
everybody died
[Laughter]
and um we had five movies with craig
uh some people say well uh [ __ ]
quantum massage wouldn't it the quality
was one of the best ones all right it
had a lot all the paranormal stuff that
happened honestly i can like you know
what it was my great [ __ ] theme song
with those keys in it [ __ ] and the
dude from white stripes
good exactly the only thing i only think
i can say bad about
the
the james bond series is the last two
movies did not have strong theme songs
spectre didn't have one no time to die
did not have a good theme song they were
still good themes but they weren't quite
as memorable yeah they didn't have that
[ __ ] bondness to them where it's real
catchy i liked that skyfall song yeah
good the one from the best one was the
[ __ ] casino royale one yeah that was
that was pretty awesome and the [ __ ]
um
uh the one from uh
[ __ ] i just said the name of the quantum
masala
yeah
i and and some of you will say quantum
i [ __ ] love quantum masala you know
what um that was a great movie i didn't
you know what i didn't like it the first
time i saw it it was like watching a
favorite time
but the second time it's still my least
favorite but i liked it a lot better
than the second time i watched it and it
was its own thing
yeah it has its own quality but all five
craig movies i thought were strong but
you have to watch them a couple times
they're all good i mean i like daniel
craig yeah gonna say he did a great job
i liked him and knives out i liked all
that kind of [ __ ] i think they're making
a secret yeah i've already said that to
[ __ ] ryan johnson he [ __ ] up star
wars but uh i think he did a great job
in [ __ ] knives man i love knives
i love who doughnuts anyway but yeah i
think they're making this equal to just
keep him away from star wars
but i'm not gonna say anything bad you
know i'm not gonna say
anything bad about see it's it's just
like everything yeah it's some people
can do stuff if it's in your wheelhouse
then it's in your wheelhouse and if it's
not i just didn't like what he did i
didn't mind what he did it's like i
didn't care that much about it but you
know what i mean uh it was it was wrong
amanda gear says are you drinking vodka
jelly it looks like pineapple juice it's
pineapple juice and coconut vodka so
it's like so it's like a pina colada
like a pina colada sure and i'm drinking
tequila now okay now is it just me
or
i don't know maybe this is me yeah do
tom hardy
and logan marshall green
look like exactly the same thing logan
marshall
he was the one that was in
wait a minute was it him that was an
upgrade
he was in the invitation the karen
kazama movie i need to see upgrades if
you haven't seen the invitation if
you're really into like really creepy
like horror thriller kind of [ __ ] holy
[ __ ] the invitation was so
good if you did you guys see like my
review of jennifer's body which was also
directed by karen kusama
watch karen kusama's other movie the
invitation
it's so
[ __ ] good and logan marshall green
was that seriously that movie the first
time i watched it i was like on the edge
of my [ __ ] seat the whole time it
made me so [ __ ] anxious cheryl says
she's never seen james box like get [ __ ]
out of here [ __ ] cheryl
go ahead and hit the button go ahead and
get the [ __ ] out of here honestly like
i'm not
if i saw them off and on like over the
years it was never my favorite thing but
sometimes they'd be on cable and it's
just kind of like ah
well i mean i grew up during like yeah
in the crossover between like the sean
connery and then like the roger moore
era which sometimes and the roger moore
ones were good but some of them were
like kind of like funny yeah yeah
comedies almost and
cheesy yes yeah almost kind of like a
superhero movie
yeah um but no uh if you've never seen
uh uh a james bond movie then um you
can't be on the show you can't be in the
comments section if you've never seen
james obama no okay sure look
go watch he's [ __ ] with me go watch
casino royale all five uh daniel craig
movies
they pretty much capture it and and put
it in a more modern context that's
pretty much who james bond was you have
a lot of [ __ ] crybabies saying well
they changed it he's not smacking girls
on the ass and a lot of the [ __ ] that
[ __ ] there's that well that's not
really part of the zeitgeist anymore if
you did that nowadays girl would punch
you right in the [ __ ] mouth it
wouldn't look as cool it wouldn't look
as cool like yeah it's not cool like
everybody's like hey what the [ __ ] are
you doing this is not it's not the 1960s
yeah but [ __ ] craig did a real good
more of a modern inter a rendition of
the of of the character all five movies
were good movie five
uh [ __ ] no time to die
homage to the entire series
all bonds
i liked it there's little easter eggs in
there my favorite still skyfall
of the daniel craig ones because the
first one they're all but they're all
good they're all good they're all worth
watching but skyfall is my favorite but
yeah um they're all worth watching oh no
and it's it's um
they're they're they're just
heart kind of hardcore
a lot more realistic than the old ones
in a certain way
it's not as glamorous i mean they're
glamorous but they're still like
grounded in reality they're a little
harder edged yeah yeah which i like i
like that even though i i like some of
the uh uh who's the bomb before it from
[ __ ] um
[ __ ]
not roger moore
wait sean connor no
the guy before daniel craig i have all
of the movies i'm just trying to
remember what oh uh pierce bros here's
president yeah
i have all the pierce bras and then i
didn't love those he's okay oh i liked
him
some of the ones that were [ __ ] uh
kind of forgotten
was the the timothy dalton ones i think
he had two he was only in two right yeah
maybe three yeah and timothy dalton was
a little bit more hard edged he was a
little bit more kind of like the daniel
craig bond and i don't have them on
blu-ray i need to get those two it was
um
living daylights
and uh i saw a living daily tomorrow
never diet i think so whatever guys i
saw those in in the movie theater
now uh the living day living in daylight
that was haha
sing
[Music]
can we talk about that a second yeah you
talk about ibarr
um
is
moving
closing
uh
ibarra used to be known as barbarella
now known as barbarella again
orlando institution downtown orlando
uh is closing its doors after 37
years that's where memento mori is our
goth night uh every month
and
they're moving somewhere
but
no one will tell me where i'm trying to
get info
uh
all that john will say who is the owner
he says we're moving so it's 13 miles
from their old location
so we'll see
um
so i don't know how that's going to go
i'm really i'm very i'm kind of upset
about this because honestly
i've been going to eyebar since
[ __ ] man the 90s
something like that
and it's kind of like my second home
and
it will be weird
like i'm glad that they're not just
closing they're moving to another
location but
[ __ ] man
that [ __ ] that location at the corner
of orange and washington right in the
downtown orlando area and it's like so
iconic
and that'll be weird like not going
there anymore
uh we are going they are doing like a
manto mori on
the on february 21st
and
demetria the dj
he writes me on facebook the other day
and he's like can you make like a
facebook
cover photo for like the last dance
momento mori that's the last one that
they're doing there hopefully they're
gonna move from memento to
the new location he's hoping to get a
friday but we're gonna see how that goes
i'm not really sure yet
but i'm not entirely sure where they're
moving it to but it's gonna be really
weird
man i've been going there since i was
like a kid
and
it's not gonna be exactly the same and
i'm just kind of like bummed out about
it i don't know how i feel about it
and it was just like a bar and
everything but
[ __ ] it's like [ __ ] cheers man i grew
up there
and
it's gonna be strange like going
somewhere else
like to go there but you know we'll see
um
cheryl says oh that's sad to lose your
watering hole but at least they're just
moving i i know well like when i first
heard it everybody said oh my god
they're closing and i was like what no
i mean
i know it's been almost 40 years but
come on but he's like no we're moving
but he won't tell me like where they're
moving to they must not know
no john knows but he doesn't want it he
doesn't want to tell anybody i got i got
a feeling it's safford
it might be
um
all john would say like i said was 13
miles
from their old location which sanford
that might be downtown sanford yeah
stanford are they trying to like compete
with mannequins
well it could be that him and maybe him
maybe him and big tom are like that's
kind of what i was thinking that's what
i was that other [ __ ] club that big
tom was working on that's right him and
scotty i'm gonna talk to tom yeah and
tom ask him because
him and scotty they bought that other or
bought or rented that other space yeah
like that theater
um that they were gonna turn into like a
more high-end type of uh like a cocktail
lounge
and
maybe they're
maybe they've all been in negotiation
i'm not really sure
so we'll see
we'll see how that goes are involved i
mean i'm gonna miss the downtown
location yeah i am
but
hopefully it'll be closer to us that'd
be nice
yeah star dog says diamonds forever was
the worst bond movie yeah i remember it
as a kid diamonds are forever i remember
the theme song i remember liking it as a
kid but i haven't seen it since the 70s
i haven't either
there's a lot of a lot of those bond
movies kind of came and went they're
kind of forgotten you can buy every one
of them for like about a hundred and
something bucks on blu-ray in a big old
collection yeah
um but i don't think i could sit through
that many of them
some of the older ones are just not they
didn't age that well
the brosnan ones i want to check out uh
[ __ ] whole um
um
[ __ ] what was it dude from living
daylights again um you just said his
name wait pierce browser or timothy
timothy dalton i got i want to get those
timothy dalton ones
that was from the 80s and i remember
liking them it was kind of like a little
i remember
living daylights being kind of like uh
almost a realistic version
when you compared it to uh
to the previous to the previous ones
what was it motherfucker's name [ __ ]
roger roger moore
roger moore was starting to become
almost like a superhero
well yeah he's like jumped down in a
sewer with a damn he would jump he'd put
on a tuxedo and then it like scuba suit
over and a scoop of pseudo bench just
jump into it
sewer and then come out
in a [ __ ] but he's like
i'm immaculate yeah and mac be
immaculate and be able to play it my
hair is perfect yeah yeah yeah you're
like wait a minute i'm like
yeah and what universe is that
you don't even smell like [ __ ] ah you
just smell like [ __ ] holy [ __ ] man i
can't even like walk across my house
without my my hair getting messed up i
don't understand he can go through now
they're talking about the economy
captured the time yeah i think connor
recaptured that those old times sure
but that's what i mean is that the i
mean the point we're making is that it's
time those chains aren't here anymore
right uh you know if you did that
nowadays that's gonna come across very
different than how it came it just
wouldn't be as
look i mean dudes got away with [ __ ]
back in those days that's fine it's just
that that kind of
some of that stuff that they did comes
off as being cheesy nowadays or
artificial or forced because well one
the movies were a lot more theatrical
and stagey back then
that's true that's they didn't have kind
of a hard edge to them
it was more of kind of like
fantasy which they were kind of spy
fantasy more
uh
but as they went on they kind of got a
little bit more rooted in reality
uh this is based on memory i haven't
seen all of connery's movies
but i really liked uh
i really liked the daniel craig movies
well as i said they were a lot more
realistically grounded they still had a
fantasy aspect to them especially the
last one in the sense that they had like
all these like exotic locations and all
this kind of like you know stunts and
technology and stuff that wasn't exactly
possible in real life but
uh so there was that but
it wasn't this whole kind of thing where
he was like a superhuman i do kind of
feel like
not so much sean connery maybe he just
kind of came across as like kind of a
sexist pig but
roger moore kind of came across as more
of like a clownish like you said like a
superhero yeah where it's kind of like
he was always
immaculate well he was also getting too
old for the role
that true that's yeah that too he was a
handsome old guy i'll get i'll give the
old devil that
yeah but he's constantly chasing after
these 23 24. yeah and it was starting to
get a little weird and he's [ __ ] 55.
like dude you're old enough to be her
dad yeah and he's not
and he's not really like a [ __ ]
jacked up [ __ ] hyper masculine
[ __ ]
you know dude he's a skinny guy
in a tux in a suit and he's oh he's just
like an old corporate guy really
and um
you know which
that might sound kind of [ __ ] up but
you said well you know
they have [ __ ] women
in porn in their 60s or 70s that are hot
as [ __ ] but they're jacked up looking
big old implants a lot of [ __ ]
hormones and uh
[ __ ] cosmetic surgeries they look
like sex machines
if you're [ __ ] 65 66
you know [ __ ] and you look like a sex
machine then yeah you're gonna get away
with being able to do porn
but if you're just your common [ __ ]
65 year old [ __ ] skinny chick [ __ ]
with your titties [ __ ] around your
ankles then no you don't really [ __ ]
belong in four but they have you know
what i mean you have to be able to look
although there's a niche for everybody
yeah but come on but sometimes the
niches are smaller and smaller come on
this niche gets smaller and smaller
okay i'm trying to think of who it is
that [ __ ]
that woman was 70 something years old
and she looks like a damn sex witch
um oh yeah you showed me her before yeah
yeah and uh oh i might like that i i
might like that cb handle better than
[ __ ] did sex sex witch sex witch yeah
can i be [ __ ] tit sex witch the thing
is is you look you see sex witch and
you're like well of course she's in a
porn movie exactly of course she's in a
poor movie you know it's like she
doesn't look out of place
but
you know roger moore started to kind of
look out of place for what he was doing
you know
uh a dude like uh i would be creeped out
if somebody like that looked like roger
moore was hitting on me and i'm
old yeah so i i'd be like a little
creeped out but you know you know
[ __ ] um sylvester stallone as old as
he is
he's a little bit more understandable
like if you put him in that role you go
yeah okay because that motherfucker's
got a huge upper body and he's [ __ ]
totally jacked up and you're like yeah
he might be able to do that
you know
and uh he's i think his wife is very
young so
yeah you know at least he looks sexual
it's just that roger moore didn't look
sexual at that age not to me
he looked a little bit like a creeper
kind of like a creeper i thought yeah
you're only going to be able to go so
far i mean to be fair though i kind of
feel like there's a storied hollywood
tradition of having these like old as
[ __ ] dudes yeah paired with these like
women that are young enough to be their
daughters well the old dudes
the old dude is a friend of theirs
they're trying to keep him working in
hollywood that's yeah
and they're like well we need the latest
it girl like this this chick is like hit
35 and she's like an old hag now so
we're gonna like put some 22 year old in
there that's like young enough to be
your goddamn daughter okay and that's
the your love interest i just remember
weird it's weird
what's the sex which is sex which is
name is
sally d'angelo sex witch
what sounds better [ __ ] [ __ ] sex witch
or sex witch [ __ ] tits
sex witch
i mean i i like it both ways
yeah
i'm gonna try to get a [ __ ] um
like i said if a clean photo of a
[ __ ]
sex witch yeah don't get me demonetized
you already showed a bug you probably
already like
probably not
honestly
like i said if you weren't here earlier
last night for whatever reason we
decided we were going to watch uh
smoking the bandit
and i was trying to remember because i
was like when this movie came out when
did that movie come out 80
wait 81 82 something like that
and i was like man that was like uh
oh
there's sally d'angelo is 70 something
years old of course that's a sex witch
yeah
okay
um
that was kind of like the heyday of
you know uh seabees or cool
kind of culture yeah and my dad was
rolling to seabees
and i was trying to remember we were
watching the movie last night i'm like
goddammit what the [ __ ] was his handle
and it was like it seemed like it was
like right on the tip of my tongue and i
couldn't [ __ ] remember
it might have been
um
might have been something to do with fig
because my dad's middle name is newton
so his nickname was fig
obviously because fig newton um
so that might have been his handle was
fig but i kind of feel like that's not
right
i don't know so i was trying to like
think and then i was like oh i wonder if
i had what did i have a handle back then
i don't know i kind of feel like
remember when remember when cbs were
cool for like 10 minutes back yeah back
in the 80s we were watching [ __ ] we
were watching smoke in the banana
what the [ __ ] it's a whole movie based
around like aren't cb's cool yeah
but it was it was cool for like i said
about 10 minutes back then maybe it was
long maybe it was longer than 10 minutes
yeah maybe it was like a month or two
there was during the time you had to pay
to talk on the telephone
and you could talk on the [ __ ] cb for
free
so therefore you were [ __ ] cheating
yeah you felt like you were getting away
with something yeah
and ever and it had like uh you know the
lingo yeah
and uh they use they use a lot of lingo
in the
in the smoking the bandit movie
although i will say
i thought i hadn't seen i saw smokey in
the bandit like a million times back in
the early 80s because it was on cable
every five seconds
um but
i
had forgotten like i thought the movie
was like a lot zanier than it was
so watching it again i'm like actually
this is a pretty quality piece of
filmmaking
you know what i'm saying
what movie smoking the bandit that's
what i'm banging i said it's a pretty
quality uh piece of filmmaking it's not
as zany as i thought it was maybe i was
confusing with the cannonball run
because that was another movie that was
more a lot more zany we should probably
watch that one too
but um spoke of the man it was actually
pretty good
it was kind of a a good
monument to the southern culture of the
time
it was true jerry [ __ ] reed in it you
guys it was true to the culture as i
remembered it
yeah um
i would watch it on
hbo all the time when i was [ __ ]
visiting my dad's [ __ ] house in
mississippi back in the summer
and i'd be like [ __ ] like yeah you
know i just
it's just funny how that's the way the
world was so at least for me you know
for every summer you know but that
that's it that was the south of the
[ __ ] early 80s
mid 80s
i think it was early 80s i think i think
that came out in 82 82 something like
that so i was probably seeing it in 83
because they would let [ __ ] age for
about a year before they would before it
would come out of cable yeah and they'd
play it and then i also remember the
part two but i don't really remember
everything that happened well now see we
have to watch part two at some point
because i did see it but i don't
remember because at the end of part one
i had forgotten that they set up
another heist yeah you know what i mean
because they did that you know they
bootlegged the cores that was like the
whole
point of the movie and then at the end
they're like oh now we're gonna like
bootleg some like it's not bootleg
they're gonna like take some clam
chowder up to boston like within a
certain time period which like i said
doesn't really have the same
uh criminal allure to it i guess because
it's not really illegal to drive clam
chowder around
like it is coors beer back then but we
were watching this and we were like even
back then even back in the 80s
technically
uh it was bootlegging
to take cores
over the mississippi river i think
but
would anybody really have cared that
much about it to like chase you for
several states no
but back then you know we bought into it
and what tom was saying and this is you
know i agreed with this it's like well
you couldn't have the bandit and the
snowman
being like
well we're gonna smuggle some drugs
across straight lines state lines
because that would have been well yeah i
mean that would have been like a lot
less sympathetic but if it was something
that was just like as innocuous as beer
right and you know the letter of the law
yeah it technically it was illegal
to
transport coors beer over the
mississippi river back then technically
but like i said nobody would give a [ __ ]
if you did it no no one would give a
[ __ ] even in the 80s yeah i think movies
like this kind of reinforced
weird ideas in the minds of the yankees
that the south was ultra [ __ ] worried
about things like alcohol and sex and
weird [ __ ] oh man no
what it was
is that
the movie was trying to make them
sympathetic
yeah
they're just like they're outlaws but
not in a way that was like offensive
right okay so it's just beer
in reality this [ __ ] would have been a
big old truck load of [ __ ] weed or
coke that's true in those days that's
what it would have been you couldn't do
that in the 80s could you because then
they'd be like no well they're actual
criminals and no one's going to
sympathize right and [ __ ] they
wouldn't probably would
wouldn't rate it as even r
you wanted something that would make
them seem like scoff laws right but not
criminals right and then every element
of this movie
was actually borrowed and lifted off a
smoke of the smoking the bandit
and it became [ __ ] um the dukes of
hazzard it's the same [ __ ] movie
well yeah that's why they made dukes it
was just this okay because they're like
oh everybody like that movie how to
let's make some more of that we got a
cool car we got a couple rednecks we got
like jumping over bridges and ponds and
whatnot
in this cool car yeah well the [ __ ]
dukes of hazard was a trans am
with a [ __ ]
army of [ __ ] lee lee's army [ __ ]
flag on the [ __ ] front bumper and
then [ __ ] and dukes of hazzard i
think that was what was that a [ __ ]
charger a dodge charger maybe with
[ __ ] wait was it i haven't seen that
[ __ ] battlefield i did used to watch
it when i was a kid i think it was a
dodge charger now tammy does make a good
point she says the main reason that
jackie gleason was chasing him was
because sally field left his son at the
altar i am actually yeah i appreciate
and actually watching it again last
night i did appreciate that they added
that
other thing so he had a personal reason
it wasn't just the beer he didn't really
care about that he was just met even
though he didn't obviously give a [ __ ]
about his son because he thought his son
was like a [ __ ] idiot yeah that was
maybe not even his yeah
somebody else's
but the thing is there's no way you came
from my loins yeah the thing is though
is that still doesn't explain why they
were paying them so much to take the
beer there
no one would pay that much to spend that
much [ __ ] course within a time limit
well the thing about bigginess and
little enos
who were the ones that put it up their
whole thing they didn't really establish
their backstory or anything
but i guess like the whole to get the
plot into motion they were like these
are just very rich people that get off
on making people do these ridiculous
things
um
just for their own amusement
they weren't cops or anything
those two who paul williams and uh the
big guy no well they were just big
enough they were the drug dealers
basically yeah they just they just
thought it was fun to let's
you know let's see if these people can
do it yeah kind of like [ __ ] like that
happened it didn't happen well like i
said it's a movie yeah it's a move it's
contrived it's a contrived situation
freaking tribe yeah but if you buy into
it it's super fun
and then the whole thing about where you
got the truck in the back and then you
got the car out in front and it's taking
all the heat for the speeding that
wouldn't work either well except that
burt reynolds kept getting distracted
because he picked up sally field and
then they were off doing their own their
own [ __ ] it was mostly useless
conversation between the two and it
mostly had to do with her
dumb ass career as a dancer
and her big old wedge in her big old
wedge shoes yeah we had shoes and
and and she danced on broadway for 12
minutes bert renner's talking about her
fat calves even though she didn't have
fat calves she's obviously got a little
skinny [ __ ] i had forgotten how much
of like how how much negging he did yeah
i'm looking at her i'm watching he's
like
yeah he did say she had fat calves and i
was like
like this is before the age of big fine
and a [ __ ] like him wouldn't
know anything about [ __ ] fat cats and
wouldn't be able to
wouldn't be able to appreciate fat
calves anyway
is this kind of funny just not i like my
fat calves
and my big fat ankle okay
[Laughter]
those aren't fat it's not like i can do
anything it's not like i can do anything
jackie gleason was just hilarious yeah
he says tammy i mean
i had forgotten i loved all his [ __ ]
all the names he came up with for his
stupid ass son yeah
like
i had forgotten how [ __ ] funny that
was and he's like not even southern
he's from brooklyn from brooklyn
although he nailed it
we're [ __ ] up here he nailed the
[ __ ]
over-the-top psychopathic [ __ ]
southern [ __ ] cop
okay and he did nail it he's supposed to
be a texas texan yeah crazy texas
sheriff and he runs into a bunch of
other cops that [ __ ] he tells those
dudes that were like stealing the shirt
from the car don't play with yourself
and he's like oh you can think about it
but don't
do just crazy [ __ ] crazy
crazy dialogue
i had forgotten how fun that was like i
said i hadn't seen that movie in
probably
christ 25 30 years i saw it a million
times when i was a kid a million times
[Laughter]
cheryl says what are we watching
tonight i don't know i thought about it
um i'm not sure
last night you know what i ended up
watching last night we watched smoking
the bandit
and then i wasn't drinking last night uh
we were just drinking uh dr pepper zero
actually
put it in our new fridge mark wahlberg
is always good in all his movies man go
ahead go ahead
i mean carol sam
boogie nights is one of my favorite
movies ever go go i [ __ ] love boogie
nights one of the greatest florida
movies of all time
his pain and gain with mark wahlberg and
the rock
yeah michael bay movie
it's very very true crime movie very
entertaining based on a real case here
in florida but the people that got
murdered were kind of shitty so you
won't feel that bad yeah the um
yeah it's on my boogie nights and
everything like that what are we well i
don't know we're gonna watch tonight's
uh yeah last night we watched smoking
the bandit and then i found what how
long we've been how long we've been
streaming
two hours and 21 minutes okay i don't
want to stream forever
well no one's streaming forever it's
only two hours now calm down
um
last night
i was kind of like man i want to watch
some like cooking [ __ ] because you know
how i do
and i found
on amazon prime
well okay
at first i thought they had this one
gordon ramsay thing what's that gordon
ramsay thing like cook with me like his
cookery course there's so many of my and
like it came up on amazon prime i'm like
oh [ __ ] i'm watching this and then like
it wouldn't let me and i'm like ugh
amazon prime and he laughed at me
because i was like amazon prime is such
a [ __ ] because it says you can
watch it but then it's like no you have
to like subscribe to this other
like the stars add-on or whatever i'm
like dude [ __ ] that [ __ ] okay
but i did find
this three-episode series that was
gordon
and his whole family from his house
and he was doing his holiday [ __ ] and i
think it was from like 2013 or 2014 or
something so he's like cooking some [ __ ]
there was like a christmas one and there
was just like a random winter one and
there was like another random winter
winter one and it had like all his his
head's wife and his kids and his mom and
all like all this other kind of crap and
like
i don't know like i got really into that
so i watched all three episodes of that
last night so that's what i was getting
into and i wasn't drunk i was like
completely sober we didn't drink last
night
but
i don't know it's a and he tells me
somebody's like well kate like when you
watch like all these cookies doesn't
that make you hungry i'm like yeah but
not in a way that makes me want to eat
food
though but it gives me like good ideas
about stuff
you know
also i think i watched the new next
level chef because they did it comes on
every sunday night and hulu adds the new
one
like the next day
so on hulu you can watch next level chef
the next morning
so i watched the next one of that
and that's a good show also if you
haven't seen that that's pretty cool
that's gordon ramsay and who are the
other [ __ ] two chefs i can't remember
they're famous too but
whatever
and uh it's kind of like the platform if
you guys remember that netflix movie
and
it's pretty good it's kind of like
masterchef but with
but mixed with the platform you know
so it's like that and i watched the new
one of that but then i watched like the
three episodes of
gordon
making holiday food for his family
damn belle just [ __ ] oh dude really
yeah
but what i was saying was that when i
watched the
the gordon ramsay holiday show
his son jack and i realized this is
going back several years because i think
this show is like from 2013.
his son jack looks exactly
like him he's like a baby gordon raves
he had the same haircut and everything
holy crap
he mostly had daughter how many kids
does that [ __ ] have four right
a million i think he has four
i think he has three daughters and a son
but his uh his son jack looked exactly
like him he had the same haircut and
everything
but yeah so i was watching that last
night that's what i was watching
after smoking the bandit
although at some point we probably
should watch cannonball run they did
have smokey in the bandit too
which
i did see
but i don't remember what happened in it
do you remember
i don't remember no i remember holding
that even the rest remodel
and
same thing with cannonball run i saw the
first cannonball run probably a zillion
times i know i saw the second one also
but i don't really remember what
happened in that one either
uh gordon has a show called uncharted
where he tries to channel bear grylls
and anthony bourdain yeah we've seen
some of that i don't know if it's still
on but i did watch some of that that's
the one where he like goes there was one
where he went to like louisiana and he
cooked like nutra and stuff like that
right
yeah tammy said son well hey polk
um
saw a funny show with gordon and two of
his buddies traveling around yeah we
watched that one that was like his uh
[ __ ] man what was that called it's
called like american road trip or
something like that
and
yeah that was actually pretty good i did
watch that i can't remember what uh
streaming service that we watched that
on but yeah we watched that one too
um i love dan bell
dead malta honestly
dan bell
there is something about him
i will watch him all day long i watch
his i usually don't watch his live
streams live because he usually does
them saturday nights he lives he's
living in ecuador now
um
well
part of the time
and he did a video
where he was comparing like an american
mall with like one in ecuador the one in
uh the us was like super dead but the
one in ecuador was like super busy and
it was like super
lush and everything and it was like
really interesting but he usually does a
live stream on saturday nights but not
always
one of the best live streams he did
recently
was one that he did because he's from
baltimore and he did one that where he
drove around baltimore and went to like
all these edgar allan poe
sites like edgar allan poe adjacent kind
of stuff like the old house he used to
live in and stuff like that and that was
actually like really really cool i
enjoyed that very very much um
grampar says my kids take after their
mother thank goodness
camp guy says guy fieri guy fieri
has a good miniseries with his family
where they're all driving all over the
country his son is in the hospitality
industry i should probably watch that
although guy fieri kind of gets on my
nerves
a little bit
i can take him in small doses but he
does kind of get on my nerves after a
while gordon has five kids i thought he
only had four
maybe he's had another one since then so
it must be there was four on that
uh did tom ever get around to watching
bullet no never no never got to worry
okay that's another one okay i'm gonna
write that down because otherwise i'm
gonna forget
um hotel hell is the best yeah i like
that one too honestly i kind of wish
they'd done more of that
although
man as i mentioned before
how the [ __ ] does
gordon ramsay have time to do all this
stuff man he has like 40 bajillion shows
every time i look he's got another
[ __ ] show coming out
i don't understand who was it well hi
what's up
she like ran it
jamie oliver has a ton of kids too
interesting i haven't watched any of his
stuff in a while i like jimmy oliver
though
but uh you know oh pokey she's like oh
wait what
let everybody see you poke
oh
look at that baby she's like yeah okay
yep yep
admire me it's fine
look at that face look at that face
she loves her daddy
she's hungry are you really yeah aren't
you getting hungry a little bit yeah
what are you gonna make uh i got taco
gossip to make tacos
or burritos
what would you rather have it doesn't
matter
either is good oh no no no i thought uh
hamburger i could make hamburgers got
buns and everything
that's right you went earlier and got
buns yep tammy says pookie yeah
look at her she's being such a good girl
you guys earlier i got this wig out of
the closet and then i had to brush it
with my hairbrush
so before i put it on i was like
brushing it and pookie was like
why are you using that brush to brush
your wig and not poopy yeah so i'm
trying to like brush the wig and she
kept like
with her paw
give me the brush
she loves the brush
she has her own brush like i have a
glove that has like
brush on it but
she loves my hair brush for whatever
reason i'm not really sure
talk about southern u.s set films makes
you think a little known film called
dirty little billy
with michael pollard i recommend western
okay i don't think i've ever seen that
one actually i'm gonna write that down
though
i'm writing down a lot of stuff this
evening
they sell wagyu beef hamburgers at my
local grocery
wake you yeah wake you i'm dropped yeah
oh everybody says oh everybody loves
pookie
pookie's the best kitty yeah she's the
best she's down there with the toys
looking at him
get your whole cluster of toys not poop
she has that now she's attacking toys
yeah yeah
beat him up beat him up
cats are hilarious says cheryl they are
she's
especially hilarious
she's a very funny little thing all
right so
you you seem like you're getting kind of
yeah i'm ready i'm ready to end the show
i gotta go get something to eat man
we'll cook we'll cook this up
okay you're gonna go make some burgers
yeah
all right that sounds good actually
all right so uh thank you everybody for
dropping by
thanks for super chats and hanging out
with us asking us questions this evening
we back on sunday talking about
a movie we don't know which one yeah
what it is but we'll find out maybe
we'll talk about where the worlds or
maybe we'll talk about smoking the
bandit here yes because we watched war
of the worlds that was good we did yeah
the year the 50 the original one the 50s
one yeah so uh we might talk about that
but yeah we'll see how it goes
short episode not really two and a half
two and a half hours that's not that
short bro i mean just we've been
spoiling y'all dude yeah i got literally
like two hours of sleep last night yeah
you're right
that's part of the reason why i'm like
let's go ahead and cook i'm exhausted
and i recorded two videos today so you
know i'm kind of worn out but yeah
uh so
yeah we'll see you guys on sunday
afternoon thanks everybody for dropping
by have a good weekend up until we see
you next time
and we will see you on sunday afternoon
bye